bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille sebastian carassou docteur
en astrophysique hauteur de la chine
notamment sensor wonder et de plein
d'autres choses sur sur internet
sébastien un jour bonjour comment ça va
à la pêche la pêche la forme c'est pas
comme s'ils avaient peu dormi la nuit
dernière mais c'est pour les faibles
n'en dormira pas pour les femmes c'est
pas vrai il faut dormir des c'est moi je
considère que quand je dors je savais
partie de mon travail
salut je suis presque plus comptant
parfois d'avoir bien dormi que d'avoir
bien travaillé genevois de payer pour ça
je me caille je le fais parce que je
peux donc peut-être commencer par ce que
tu peux nous parler un peu de ton
parcours scolaire mon parcours scolaire
à dans mon parcours
alors on peut parler d'un parcours
scolaire mon parcours intellectuel c'est
deux choses un peu décorrélé donc mon
parcours scolaire il ya vraiment
classique j'ai fait j'ai fait un bac s
ensuite je suis parti faire une prépa
maths physique que j'ai fait à alice et
kléber à strasbourg
j'ai passé deux belles années là-bas et
puis je me suis dit en fait j'ai pas
très envie de faire une école
d'ingénieurs donc je suis revenu dans le
système de la facture je suis arrivé je
suis parvenu
et donc j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle le
magistère de physique fondamentale c'est
une espèce de de formation hybride entre
un licence 3 et un master 1
voilà spécialisé en physique
fondamentale que j'ai continué en dans
une dans un masters d'astrophysique et
ensuite je fais une parcours classique
une thèse thèse en astrophysique que
j'ai réalisée à l'institut
d'astrophysique de paris où j'ai étudié
les galaxies pendant trois ans 3 trois
belles années et et voilà et après je me
suis dit qu'est ce que je peux faire de
plus précaire que chercheur et je suis
devenu vidéaste sur la chaîne youtube le
sense of wonder à temps plein maintenant
les gars disent que tu goûtes tu
considères que tu es vidéaste à temps
plein sur scéne thunder bon on va dire à
70%
la notion de temps plein est vraiment
vraiment très étrange parce que j'ai
jamais été à temps plein sur quoi que ce
soit même pendant ma tête j'étais
désarroi de mai directeur et du coup tu
mon parcours intellectuel avant parcours
intellectuel il est plus chaotique
il est plus chaotique alors l'avait
raconté dans un article du monde qui est
sorti en février de l'année dernière
ça m'a valu pas mal de pas mal de bugs
on va dire en fait je viens de germes de
la réunion à la base d'une villa un peu
rural avec une famille qui n'était pas
du tout dans les sciences en fait je
suis la première personne dans ma
famille qui fait des sciences haut
niveau au niveau professionnel en voilà
et en fait je n'avais pas du tout de
sensibilité scientifique alors que
j'étais un grand fan de science fiction
quand j'étais tout petit donc donc
j'étais un fan de star wars star wars a
occupé une énorme partie de neige n'est
signé mais ça va plutôt bien servi parce
que ça m'a ouvert l'esprit de
sensibilité aux sciences par la science
fiction est en fait voilà la science
fiction a une grosse influence sur sur
mon parcours intellectuel et j'étais
aussi un gros rat de bibliothèque donc
j'allais j'allais dans la bibliothèque
municipale de ma ville petite île qui
qui était ouverte tous les week end donc
j'y passais mes journées
et en fait je passais mes journées à
faire des allers retours entre les
rayons science et les rayons les hôtes
et ris parce que je ne savais pas trop
faire la différence entre les deux parce
que personne ne m'avait dit c'est quoi
la différence entre une connaissance
fiable et une connaissance pas fiable et
du coup je me suis tout farsi quoi les
livres sur les fantômes les livres sur
les ovnis
livre / absolument n'importe quoi la
sorcellerie et c est pour tout ça pour
moi c'était des connaissances qualité au
même niveau ils étaient au même rayon
ce n'est pas au rayon mais ce n'était
pas très loin puisque aujourd'hui il
pourrait être nommé à riom bas à la fnac
par exemple
malheureusement le rayon l'ésotérisme de
la fnac est beaucoup plus fourni que le
rayon science un jeu c'est un truc qui
me désole personnellement et
et donc voilà donc j'ai passé plusieurs
années dans ce truc là et puis vint les
débuts d'internet en termes de
l'internet explose à peu près quand je
quand je suis petit donc j'ai grandi sur
internet et j'ai grandi sur sur les
forums conspirationnistes j'ai grandi
sur en regardant des documentaires
américain mel doublé sur les chaînes à
l'éthique controversé les choses sont
les chasseurs de fantômes des choses sur
voilà il faut documentaire sur on n'a
jamais marché sur la lune etc
je go ben et alors tout absolument tout
et pendant plusieurs années j'avais
aucune personne pour me contredire là
dessus donc voilà donc un vent de
vouloir devenir astrophysiciens je
voulais devenir parapsychologue et la
parapsychologie c'est la fameuse
audience où on essaie de le chercher les
phénomènes paranormaux en tout cas
essayer de confirmer les phénomènes
paranormaux
c'est pas du tout une science parce que
l'idée c'est de confirmer quelque chose
qu'on voudrait qu'ils soient vraies et
pas deux et pas de chercher une vraie
description du monde
donc voilà je voulais être le premier à
trouver la clé secrets de la télépathie
les secrets des fantômes et qu'est-ce
qui doit bien après la mort et ses airs
et pendant plusieurs années ça a été ça
et je suis arrivé en prêt pas
miraculeusement parce que j'étais pas
trop mauvais en sciences à l'époque
parce que j'étais aussi fan parce que je
lisais aussi des bouquins d'hubert
reeves je lisais aussi des bouquins de
sciences quoi pour moi c'est ça rentrait
pas du tout en contradiction parce que
ça permet pas des mêmes choses et de
toute façon
voilà quand j'avais pas les bases en
épistémologie pour pour trier le bon
grain de l'ivraie
vous délivrez pardon et donc voilà
quand je suis arrivé en préparant fait
il
un truc c'est que j'ai commencé à
découvrir des sites sur le scepticisme
scientifique c'est des sites américains
le blog de philippe laüt la bad
astronomy qui est sur slate maintenant
aujourd'hui et grâce à la grâce à
philippe light indirectement j'ai réussi
à découvrir le travail de l'astronome
carl sagan qui a été la plus grosse
influence intellectuelle de ma vie parce
que carl sagan c'était un astronome qui
a vécu dans le papa spirituel c'est mon
papa thierry tulasne exactement et
parfois j'essaie d'imiter sa coiffure et
parfois on me dit arrête d'imiter
attaque cette fois sur un site et couper
les cheveux des pizzerias et tout le
monde en est plus là dans le monde se
porter voilà donc karzaï a été vraiment
la grosse influence de ma vie alors il
est surtout connu pour avoir fait un
documentaire magistrale dans les années
80 qui s'appelait au cosmos et qui est
l'un des plus célèbres documentaire
jamais produit donc aujourd'hui il ya
neil degrasse tyson qui a repris le
flambeau pour faire une suite même 2
suit celui qui doit sortir la semaine
pour le faire dans l'est dans les mois à
venir
c'était mieux avant bah c'était beaucoup
mieux parce que ça reste un même public
il y avait vraiment quelque chose de
très personnel dans cosmos avec un un
rythme qui était assez lent une
narration qui était très personnel avec
voilà le 15 à gan c'était quelqu'un qui
ressentait la science en
émotionnellement autant que
qu'intellectuellement et aujourd'hui
j'avais reboot de cosmos on n'est plus
sûr du documentaire américain avec des
effets spéciaux partout et des musiques
épiques qui sont pas vraiment dans le
même état d'esprit et je pense que ça
joue sur comment est-ce que gelée
ressenti ce reboot mais mais à l'époque
où je découvre alors je suis en première
année de prépa deuxième année de prépa
je découvre cosmos et alors là c'est une
révolution dans ma vie quoi c'est aussi
une année où j'allais avec des danses
appelle ça des congrès d'ufologie pour
savoir voilà c'est quelle quelle est la
source de propulsion des ovnis alors on
n'a pas ça dépend maintenant des
phénomènes aérospatiaux non identifiés
plutôt que des ovnis à l'époque c'était
johnny et est donc est donc dans ce
genre de congrès tu avais tu avais de
tout quoi tu avais des astronautes qui
avait réparer hubble tu avais le
l'ancien ministre de la défense des
grande bretagne
tu avais des pilotes qui avaient vu des
zones heat avait des des personnalités
scientifiques très controversé qui
donnait présentaient leur système de
propulsion de soucoupe volante
alors ce genre de truc ça c'était assez
surréaliste maintenant qu'avec le recul
mais l'est mais à l'époque j'étais
j'étais à fond et dans quoi et c'est à
partir de la hausse à partir de cartes
hagen qui est aussi un gros promoteurs
du mouvement sceptiques aux états unis a
été l'éditeur du celtic de l'ascap 6 du
journal de journée le losc et pixar
descriptif qu'américains et donc voilà
il a énormément contribué notamment avec
des bouquins sont son bouquin que j'ai
découvert un peu plus tard qui s'appelle
the demon run the world qui est une
espèce de bible sur le scepticisme
scientifique sur comment comment est ce
que la science est la meilleure façon
d'appréhender le monde aujourd'hui afin
de défendre et moi ça c'est ce genre de
lecture a complètement changé ma façon
de voir les choses et depuis j'essaie de
promouvoir ce genre ce genre d'idée quoi
de savoir que voilà que la science est
non seulement une bonne manière la moins
pire des manières de comprendre le monde
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est aussi revoir
revenir oui bah ça selon certains salons
de critères que tu que tu veux bien sûr
mais voilà non seulement la science et
ne pas trop mauvaise manière de décrire
le monde mais aussi ses porteurs d'une
certaine vision quiconque honteux
ressentir de manière très très émotive
en fait c'est la nation c'est aussi une
construction qui permet de contenir des
histoires sur des os convient ou est-ce
qu'on va quelques lequel quelle échelle
à quelle échelle on doit regarder le
monde pour ce pour se comprendre pour
comprendre les uns les autres et c'est
porteur d'une histoire super riches est
super belle et c'est ça que j'essaie de
promouvoir à l'heure actuelle voilà
parce que du coup car s'ils gagnent ils
parlé directement de pas de devenir de
malouda ordonnance dans un divan devant
tyloo r en fait il parle il part de ces
différents sujets là alors il parle il
parle d'ovni parce qu'il recevait des
dizaines et dizaines d'appels de gens
qui qui prétendait soit avoir été enlevé
par des hommes niçois soit voilà qui
avait vu des ovni à plusieurs degrés ces
quatre ans sur des emails comme ça j'en
ai reçu quelques-uns j'en ai reçu
quelques-uns alors pas énormément parce
que j'en parle pas beaucoup publiquement
de ce genre de questions alors j'imagine
qu'après ce podcast on aurait peut-être
astronomiques comme ça wayne rooney qui
plus sur des sujets un peu plus clivants
vraiment j'essaie d'éviter les sujets
clivants en général pour l'instant on
verra on verra comment ça se passe plus
tard mais pour moi je vois vraiment
l'astronomique comme une porte d'entrée
vers les sciences ou alors je triche un
peu parce que l'astronomie c'est des
belles images c'est pas de base la
culture populaire
voilà ce trône au miquel quelque chose
de positif et je joue de cela énormément
j'aime bien jouer de ça parce que moi ça
me touche c'est évidemment mais je vois
pas l'astronomie comme une fin en soi
quoi tu joues à l'astronomie comme un
moyen de voir le monde de manière
scientifique et qui peuvent amener à des
réflexions sur d'autres sujets après je
suis pas sur le réchauffement climatique
sur sur des sujets qui touchent nos
sociétés et il ya peut-être un rapport
un peu plus politique à partir de là
quoi avec ça c'est qu'elle que tu vois
aujourd'hui
ouais c'est qu'à l'époque c'était pas le
cas à l'époque à l'époque c'était
vraiment ans depuis que j'ai 12 ans je
voulais devenir astrophysicien et
c'était mon ma prime directive pendant
pendant dix ans quoi et depuis que
depuis qu'il a fait une ima thèse est
que je me suis forgé une conscience un
peu plus politique et de voilà du rôle
du chercheur dans la société
j'ai évolué un petit peu dans ce rapport
là il ya toujours cette dimension la
science c'est une belle vision du monde
et je suis persuadé que 99% des gens ne
savent pas le voit la sauce et épaisse
de construction qu'on a fait depuis 400
ans qui est absolument belle et qu'ils
méritent d'avoir une place de choix dans
notre culture
ce qui n'est pas encore le cas
aujourd'hui quoi on a des visions
extrêmement biaisée de la science dans
la société a toujours depuis les années
40 cette image du savant fou qui peut
détruire le monde
sur 1 sur un claquement de doigts mais
c'est pas ça à la science aujourd'hui la
science et voilà un effort collectif
pour mieux comprendre le monde et est de
savoir comment ça fonctionne quelles
valeurs
c'est sensé
auf l'été je trouve que c'est vachement
important pour répondre aux enjeux qu'on
a à l'heure actuelle qui sont souvent
des enjeux technoscientifique quoi la
majorité des problèmes qu'elles ont fait
face aujourd'hui 11 en soi une cause
scientifique soit une solution
scientifique donc à un moment pas que
évidemment on a essayé des choix de
société aussi un côté culturel qu'il
faut prendre en compte mais il ya le
côté scientifique qui n'est pas à
négliger
est-ce que promouvoir une vraie l'image
de la science a pas idéaliser n'est pas
déformé non plus c'est super important
si on veut rendre le monde meilleur en
général quoi qu'elles fassent qu'on aura
l'occasion de redire bien même l'aspect
culturel se comprend enfin peut
s'analyser via le prisme de la science
et les sétois les actions plus est fait
par exemple sur un maximum de personnes
sais tu dis aussi scientifiquement tout
à fait une remarque intéressante qu'elle
me fait du coup en techno dance et que
du coup tatinghem questionner ttt
croyances pseudo scientifique mais pas
par des arguments direct c'est d'abord
par une fascination pour l'astrophysique
way qui t'a permis c'est l'émotion qui
me fait qui me fait changer c'est
l'émotion qui était créée par cette
réalisation que on est on est tout petit
face à l'immensité de l'univers et on
intègre en face aliments l'immensément
petit d'immensément petit c'est joli
comme ans qui nie pas infiniment petit à
le mathématicien c'est surtout parce que
bien finie existe une conférence qui
veut d'un brillant mathématicien
excellente conférence n'y a bien que
sylvie tube aille un petit peu lent à m
les vidéos sur youtube on parle d'une
conférence que j'ai donné à lyon
sciences oui donc voila moi c'est
vraiment les mêmes je suis passé par
l'émotion pour arriver à une vision
scientifique du monde et je pense que la
dimension émotionnelle il faut passer
par là quoi puisque exploiter un billet
de l'humanité si on était tous des
créatures rationnelle par excellence
alors définir rationnelle mais si on
était tous d'ailleurs si on doit faire
passer certaines idées dans la société
on doit se servir d'eux comment
fonctionne on doit réfléchir à comment
communiquer notre message et connaissent
le message il va être interprété
et ben ça ça implique de des
connaissances minimales en psychologie
en psychologie sociale en sociologie
ouais de savoir quels rapports de force
au sens au fond en politique aussi
voilà comme comment nos idées évoluent
dans le monde des idées mais aussi dans
le monde réel où il ya des contraintes
au niveau institutionnel au niveau
individuel haut niveau voilà et ça ça
m'intéresse énormément quoi tient ce
genre de questions ça monte ça me fait
mal réveillé la nuit en mode qu'est ce
que qu'est-ce que je fais ce que je peux
faire pour maximiser mon impact en tant
qu'individu du coup peut-être avancer un
petit mot sur ton parcours qu'est ce que
des gouttes of tata depuis douze ans il
est remonté on doit y être
astrophysiciens donc si ça peut
peut-être toujours voulu être chercheur
il ya eu une étincelle un moment qu'il
ya une raison pour laquelle
astrophysiciens en particulier alors là
c'est une raison mais elle est ridicule
alors je suis un grand fan de disney et
j'ai grandi avec le disney et notamment
il ya un disney qui m'a beaucoup marqué
qui s'appelle la planète au trésor
c'est un film qui est complètement passé
à côté de la culture populaire personnes
peau dessinent les gens qui ont vu la
peine est de 13 heures en fait la
planète au trésor c'est c'est le récit
de l'île au trésor de robert louis
stevenson
mais dans l'espace du coup c'est encore
mieux et donc dans ce film bordas le
comic relief de
de service qui est un espèce de chien
anthropomorphe qui se trouve être un
astrophysicien dont quatre offices du
chien et ce type il était génial parce
que non seulement il était superbe
donc voilà l'empathie et créer de base
il avait aussi une [ __ ] de maison avec
une carte 3d de l'univers et je me dis
mais génial
alors j'avais vu le film j'étais
tellement fan que j'avais acheté la
novélisation du film dont j'avais lu le
livre du film et donc c'est là que j'ai
rencontré ce mot l'astrophysicien savais
pas ce que ça voulait dire à l'époque où
j'ai tapé sa / / / lycos
et oui parce qu'ils connaissent par les
états et donc voilà donc la personne
autour de moi savez ce que ça voulait
dire astrophysiciens donc je peux
j'avais ces espèces de connaissances
ésotériques d'un bar mots que personne
ne connaissait donc gelé le shérif
pendant plusieurs années
et donc voilà j'ai c'est là où j'ai
commencé à lire des bouquins sur
l'univers des imageries les bouquins de
vulgarisation et en fait je suis jamais
arrêté de lire des bouquins de
vulgarisation même aujourd'hui je
continue je trouve ça je trouve ça
génial je vais me mettre la science en
récit d'aller au delà des faits bruts de
la collection ou fait là pour aller
plutôt vers une vision un peu intégrée
du monde
moi ça me plaît du coup tu t'es lancé
dedans c'était c'était que c'était
difficile au début août avec mais ça
tâter eu des moments de doute c'est dire
non je peux pas faire ça des moments de
doute alors évidemment il ya toujours
les moments de doute où tu te dis que tu
es pas assez malin pour faire ça moi
j'étais relativement un bon mais j'ai
pas un élève excellent non plus voilà je
mets par mes parents voulaient pas
forcément que je le fasse astrophysicien
déjà parce qu'il savait pas ce que ce
que ça voulait dire
ensuite quand ils ont vu que je suis
passé en prépa pas non plus que je suis
passé à la fac etc ils ont complètement
est tellement complètement soutenu dans
ce processus là merci énormément
d'ailleurs mais mais ouais il ya eu
toujours ces petits moments de syndrome
de l'imposteur quoi qui traverse
forcément n'importe quelle personne à
tout moment de ses études
mais après tu finis par te dire que ben
si tu essayes pas mais tu n'as aucune
chance d'y arriver de toute manière donc
autant aller aussi loin que l'univers te
laisse faire et et après au moins
taratata y c'est comme ça que j'ai
vaincu un syndrome de l'imposteur
alors aujourd'hui il y en a un autre qui
est le syndrome de l'imposteur du
vidéaste parce que voilà je suis un bébé
vidéaste et j'ai pas la formation
vidéaste et je vous dis or cette image
elle est dégueulasse tendance est donc
c'est bon il faut toujours se battre
contre eux c'est un nom de l'apostât
j'ai l'impression que c'est quelque
chose qui bloque énormément de gens et
on peut à quai le syndrome de
l'imposteur en se donnant des buts très
précis a atteint et je pense que ouais
c'est une bonne manière de d'être
heureux dans la vie
[Rires]
dire que baho pire c'est un échec mais
pas autant qu'on trouve du plaisir tout
à fait affaire aux tricks com ou comme
disait 90% des road movie l'important
c'est pas la destination sept voyages
quoi exactement est légal et clients
particuliers c
alors les galaxies c'est lié au fait que
je voulais comprendre les choses et plus
les plus vastes de l'univers alors il ya
deux choses dans le temps de l'univers
qui sont les plus vastes univers
lui-même
et puis il ya les galaxies et recueillir
univers et aussi quel multivers
multivers quand on trouvera l'existence
du multivers je suis très motivé mais en
attendant on va dire que pour l'instant
la bleue c'était soit l'unité derrière
soi avec la cosmologie donc la science
qui étudie l'univers en tant qu'objet
soient les plus gros objets de l'univers
qui sont les galaxies qui sont liées aux
grands filaments de la toile cosmique et
donc moi ça me fascinait dans en
astrophysique c'était vraiment ça ce
côté des grandes tailles on va répondre
au big one grandes questions de tous les
temps comment léo l'univers il évolue
par opposition officielle des particules
qui se posaient petite question
extrêmement petites questions
de l'avis de m
recevoir des mails incendiaires mais
c'est pas vrai c'est pas du tout mais
voilà moi c'est moi ce que je voulais
étudier c'était ça il y avait aussi un
rapport à l'image voix lui les galaxies
ccbbo par je ne sais pas si vous avez
déjà vu des images de galaxies
séité peinture ouais c'est vrai dire il
ya des belles peintures de galaxies dire
mais voilà il ya des couleurs partout on
pourrait passer des heures à juste
regarder une grande image de galaxies
parce qu'on a des superbes images avec
hubble avec et au plein de plein de
télescopes qui nous donnent des
divisions ultra détaillés et ultra
coloré de l'univers est vraiment ce côté
esthétique qui me plaisait beaucoup
on peut raconter de belles histoires
avec juste une image de galaxies mais
une histoire qui qui qui est lié à notre
histoire en fait parce que s'il avait
pas de galaxy pad et des toiles partie
les pas des toiles y aurait pas de
planète si les pâtes planète y aurait
pas d'humains voilà donc on est liée à
tout ça et moi c'était ça qui me une
espèce de voile à de volonté de
transcendance par la science il est beau
c'est ma ville même et c'est un peu
c'est un peu l'idée savoir qu'on
déconnecte et à quelque chose de
beaucoup plus grand et je voulais plus
grande série galaxy
parce que tu es dans ta tête tu es tu
dis pas l'ags les gtt titillant les
galaxy alors les wheeler d'ailleurs il
faut définir ce que c'est les galaxy
pour les auditeurs qui connaissent pas
donc les galaxies c'est les énormes
collection des toiles à des centaines de
milliards dans chaque galaxie ces
espèces de gros nuages qui va voir plein
de plateforme qui peut prendre des
formes de deux cyclones ou des forme de
ballon de rugby
il ya énormément de tailly possible etc
et les galaxies et des évolué au fil de
l'histoire de l'univers et il y en a
les derniers relevés havas compte deux
mille 2000 milliards de galaxies qu'on
pourrait observer avec le télescope est
théoriquement et donc voilà était il ya
une immense diversité de formes de
galaxies de couleurs de taille etc et
aujourd'hui en 2019 on n'a pas une
histoire intégrée et complète des galaxy
dans leur contexte cosmique on n'a pas
de compréhension vraiment globale de
tous les processus qui se passe dans
l'évolution d'une galaxie notamment
parce que les galaxies c'est des
systèmes complexes qui ont énormément de
processus qui se passe à l'intérieur
je sais pas il ya des trous noirs qui
jette enfin il est tout noir qui liquide
qui envoie énormément d'énergie dans les
délais xi centre de chaque galaxie il ya
un immense trou noir qui peut avaler de
la matière mais aussi chauffer de la
matière et empêcher la formation des
étoiles autour d'eux on a des supernovae
donc des explosions d'étoilés massives
qui éjecte les éléments qu'ils ont
forgée en leur coeur pendant des
millions d'années et qui enrichissent
l'univers de plus en plus chimiquement
on a des étoiles qui y vivent qui meurt
on a des planètes qui se forme on a du
gaz
on est de la poussière qui modifie les
images des galaxies
on allait les filaments de la toile
cosmique qui sont les plus grandes
structures de l'univers une espèce de
deux toiles d'araignées de fait de faute
de gaz et de matière noire qui joue sur
l'évolution des galaxies
on a des galaxies qui entre en fusion
pour former des plus grosses galaxies et
qui ont fait ça depuis 14 milliards
d'années
plus 13 milliards d'années depuis que
les premières galaxies existe donc voilà
il ya énormément de choses qui se
passent à des échelles de taille qui
vont de trous noirs stellaires donc
quelque chose de relativement petit pour
une galaxie à quelque chose d'énorme
comme les grandes structures l'univers
et on est sur des échelles de grandeur
qui on a su emmener sur 22 échelle de
grandeur pour comprendre l'histoire
complète d'une galaxie il faut
reproduire 22 échelle de grandeur dans
nos simulations numériques dans
dans nono d'équations etc c'est juste
impossible aujourd'hui
du coup on autant on comprend très bien
ce qui se passe sur les très grandes
structures de l'univers sur comment est
ce que la toile cosmique a évolué depuis
depuis les 13 derniers milliards
d'années autant les petites choses comme
les galaxy alors relativement petit mais
petit par rapport aux la toile cosmique
ça comprend beaucoup moins parce qu'à
cause de tous ces processus qui sont
extrêmement dures à simuler la
turbulence dans les gaz enfin on s'est
vraiment c'est vraiment un cauchemar
d'astrophysiciens quoi le maire mais
c'est un cauchemar qui est de plus en
plus traitées de manière sérieuse parce
que on a des super ordinateurs on a des
super calculateurs qui qui doublent leur
puissance chaque année et qui nous
permettent de simuler les processus de
plus en plus petit dans évidemment en
dessous de l'élément de résolution
l'équivalent du pixel sur une image on
doit casey énormément de trucs donc
qu'ils sont de la physique niekro
scopique donc comment les gaz évoluons
chimiquement comment l'énergie et des
supernovae elle est envoyée supernova
une supernova cette poule petit à
l'échelle d'une galaxie 1 voilà il se
passe tellement de choses à 17 tellement
variés que pour l'instant on est obligé
de mettre plein de processus physiques
sous le tapis et mais plus on avance
dans la puissance de calcul et dans la
compréhension des phénomènes qu'on
observe plus on a des chances de
comprendre
bah pourquoi est-ce qu'on a des galaxies
aujourd'hui en forme de en forme de
spirale pourquoi on est des galaxies
bleus pour prendre des galaxies rouge
pourquoi on n'a pas de galaxies verte
voilà c'est l'axé vert il n'y a pas
vraiment de galaxies les recommencer la
même raison pour laquelle il ya pas d
pad étoiles vertes et des étoiles bleues
et des toiles rouges et donc des
galaxies bleus et des galaxies roulait
alors là c'est lié à la température des
étoiles plus l'histoire les chaudes plus
nettoie les bleus plus ni toile et
froide plus une étoile rouge celle
inverse des robinets mai mais il ya peu
des toiles verte et du coup il ya peu de
galaxies verte
ce que parce que tu parles du est-ce que
la couleur de l'étoile des pointes de
uniquement de cette envergure ans et sa
dépendance à température mais ça dépend
si bas de son âge en fait ça dépend de
son âge et de sa masse donc les grosses
étoiles ont tendance des étoiles les
plus massives elles ont tendance à être
très très chaude est donc allé très très
bleu les étoiles qui sont en fin de vie
elles ont tendance à être plutôt rouge
ce qu'on appelle des géantes rouges
donc c'est le sait le destin de notre
soleil dans 5 milliards d'années les
étoiles et plus petit qu'on appelle des
naines rouges elles sont pas par
définition rouge une des rares fois où
les astronomes nomme des choses bien moi
ça va c'est entre vous par les jeunes
biologistes sont plus critiques
peut-être alors à mais il ya un truc
encore les maladresses h 06 les
triplettes mêlées même les naines rouges
finissent par devenir bleu parce que
leur luminosité à grande et le
grandissent au fil du temps les faits
donc on devrait les à telenet bleus dans
les appels tourner dans le rouge c'est
donc voilà et donc voilà ça tout ça va
jouer dans cette espèce de grandes sagas
cosmique de l'évolution des galaxies
mais globalement la couleur d'une étoile
hors effet doppler on va dire c'est
uniquement le rayonnement du corps noir
c'est ouais c'est ça by mais énormément
du corps noir et dépend de la
température de l'étoile et la
température de l'étoile elle dépend de
l'âge de l'étoile le plus lu toi les
vieilles plus elle est chaude parce que
son coeur est de plus en plus denses et
donc plus son carré danse plus il ya des
réactions thermonucléaires dans son
terrain et c'est ça qui fait briller les
étoiles et c'est pour ça que les étoiles
sont de plus en plus chaude au fur et à
mesure qu'elle évolue genre notre soleil
par exemple
il a sa luminosité elle augmente de 10 %
par milliards d'années ce qui fait que
dans un milliard d'années on peut
s'attendre à ce que l'intégralité de la
vie complète sur terre s'effondre parce
que parce qu il fera trop chaud alors on
sait qu'il a une température maximale
que le corps humain peut supporter avant
de mourir ses 37 degrés donc c'est la
température du corps humain
donc si on met un humain dans un
environnement de 37 degrés ou plus
pendant pendant une semaine il va mourir
voilà c'est dommage mais on sait qu'il
ya des simulations qui ont montré par
exemple que dans un milliard d'années
si on veut être précis là tout plaide
toute la surface de la terre sera au
dessus de 37 devait donc on peut dire
que à ce moment là ailleurs à plus
d'humains oui peut-être plus d'humains
bien qu'on rangeait sa des ports de
spectateurs entre-temps mais voilà il y
aura toujours des extrêmophiles des
espèces de petites bactéries de microbes
qui vivent dans des lieux insolites
insolite un prodige inouï de
l'atmosphère de sa dépendance nécessaire
mais à partir du moment où l'atmosphère
devient tellement chaude que l'eau à
l'état liquide peut plus exister
et ça ça arrivera dans deux milliards
d'années c'est que les simulations
milices
quand la luminosité du soleil aura
augmenté de 20%
là on l'a on aura on atteint des
températures sur terre qui qui font que
toute l'eau s'évapore et se barre dans
l'espace par des processus un peu un peu
complexe et le rayonnement solaire qui
va casser les molécules d'eau de l'océan
et ça va casser la lho ch2o donc c'est
de deux atomes d'hydrogène et un atome
d'oxygène et je trouve que l'oxygène
c'est l'élément le plus léger qui existe
donc
et donc c'est plus propice à
l'échappement dans l'espace donc on aura
littéralement l'eau de l'eau de la terre
qui l'a s'échapper dans l'espace dans
deux milliards d'années et à partir du
moment où on a plus d'eau ben ya plus de
il a publié plus de vie quoi tout
simplement c'est aussi simple que ça
donc voilà on a deux milliards d'années
pour créer une utopie intergalactique 1
milliards d'années pour nous si on veut
pas que les bactéries le fasse avant
nous mais voilà ça nous laisse sans vous
laisser un peu de temps mais pas tant
que tant que ça quand même à l'échelle
de l'univers magique en rien si on passe
des choses en des milliards d'années
quand même façon et guardian et on a le
temps de faire un certain très culte et
même qu l'hypothèse de riemann n'est pas
prouvée dans ce maquis voter ce dernier
s'est retrouvé dans la nuance est
derrière michael froman comment tu veux
aller mater pour éviter ces trois
missiles près de prestige et des
mathématiques
ah oui mais pour le prestige c'est
beaucoup c'est pas juste le prestige
c'est pour l'instant une big crunch a
été grande question assassiné lyne en
question c'est une question qui va au
delà de l'univers ce n'est pas un
problème si tu me l'expliquer comme tu
expliques d'habitude je pense que tu
pourras me convaincre que ces deux
c'est beau mais c'est par le min tit
vite que moi
cet homme qui sert à rien face à
l'étoile plus intéressant que il ajouté
sam hamad mais c'est de lui prestigieuse
d'après communauté mathématique non
parce que je reviens à ma question va
occuper parce qu'une étoile pour être
verte du coup c'est sympa un peu ça ne
devrait pas au soleil pas non plus sur
les blancs le soleil il est blanc alors
il aimait la majeure partie de son
énergie dans le vert dans le jaune vert
à peu près à 520 nanomètres si je me
souviens bien et est en fait ouais le
soleil les pages jaunes comme on décide
généralement il est blanc s'il regarde
dans l'espace mais voilà le en fait un
corps noir ça dépend de la température
et donc les conditions qui font que les
corps noir rayonne fonctions il ya peu
des toiles qui sont ouvertes en pratique
alors y'a rien une étoile verte la plus
chaude non plus froides pendant que le
soleil une étoile verte 1 serait je ne
sais pas la légion dans la pose une
colle par contre un second épisode de
long terme cosmiques sur pourquoi ya pas
d toile verte
donc j'avais vu il ya quelques années
mais je me rappelle plus de ses dix pas
autant qu'il ya presque à ses vidéos sur
le cyan juifs aux couleurs qui s'appelle
le scion faut voir la vidéo de
l'interface me crois qu'ils en parlent
que moi cela qu'il fasse moins bien et
de coupes ordinateur séparé de corps
était alors dans ma thèse j'ai étudié
comment est-ce que les galaxies et vous
lui en taille en formes et en couleurs
au fil de l'histoire de l'univers et
pour ça j'ai utilisé une approche qui
est un peu nouvelle qui est de simuler
des images de télé stop lorsque j'ai
fait c'est qu'il ya plein de l'image de
télescopes où on voit plein de galaxie
alors c'est pas si vous tapez chant
profond de hubble sur google vous allez
tourner sur une de mes images
astronomiques préféré qu'ils aient
cessées hubble qui pendant 11 jours
regarder un tout petit point du ciel et
la regarder pendant 11 jours d'affilée
les prises obscures c'est ça ouais il
n'y avait rien en fait dont on voit rien
dans cette zone de l'univers si on
regarde pas l'univers pendant 11 jours
donc si on n'accumule pas des photons
sur le télescope pendant pendant 11
jours et en fait à la base c'est un vrai
pari de faire cette image parce qu'on
savait pas ce qu'on allait y trouver
peut-être rien il trouve actuellement
on va essayer de faire la photo plus
ennuyeuse et les l'hiver van doorn le
pixel le pull noir possible les imagine
toi à la place de de l'astrophysicien
qui a proposé sa à l'époque on va bien
on va prendre le télescope voeux les
plus chers c'est le pointer pendant 11
jours sur deux y créa est alors c'était
très controversé à l'époque dans les
années 90 mais onze jours plus tard en
début c'était incroyable image qui le
veut le fond le chant profond de hubble
où on avait plusieurs milliers de
galaxies leurs dizaines de milliers de
galaxies sur sur une minuscule zone du
ciel alors pour se représenter la
surface de l'image que ça représente il
suffit de prendre une aiguille on à tête
d'une aiguille de la mettre dans votre
main droite et de la tenir à bout de
bras comme ça et donc ce que vous voyez
en terme de surface 2
du chas de l'aiguillé ça constitue la
zone du ciel pour que hubble a observé
pendant 11 jours et là dedans là dedans
en trop qu'il ya des dizaines de
milliers de galaxies et donc c'est une
image qui est absolument en révolte qui
a révolutionné l'astrophysique parce que
ça nous montrait que non seulement
l'univers est beaucoup plus populeux que
ce qu'on pensait au départ mais qu'il ya
aussi plein de galaxies dans l'univers
de mille milliards de galaxies qu'on
peut potentiellement observer et à est
en fait voilà c'est le genre d'image que
je reproduis aujourd'hui donc ces
espèces de 2 d'image de télescope avec
plein de petits blob convois convoi plus
ou moins bien et donc voilà l'idée
c'était qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de
plus fiable pour pour étudier
l'évolution des galaxies
le truc le plus fiable c'est d'utiliser
des images parce que la majeure partie
de l'information qui nous vient de mon
univers et ne vient des photos des
images ce qu'on a autre chose que les
photons ouais on a autre chose que les
photos on a les rayons cosmiques par
exemple qui tenait ses douches de
particules qui nous arrive
continuellement de l'espace
interstellaire des particules
énergétiques dont certaines ont sait pas
d'où ils viennent mais certaines
viennent du soleil certaines viennent
des supernovae certains voient là et qui
se baladent dans la galaxie pendant
pendant pendant longtemps on a les
neutrinos les neutrinos cdh et autres
petites particules qui ont une masse
extrêmement faible et qui interagissent
très peu avec la matière et qui sont
produits dans des environnements ultra
énergétique comme les supernovae et le
coeur du soleil
voilà et il ya aussi depuis 2008 15 les
ondes gravitationnelles qui a
révolutionné l'astronomie
parce qu'on a
on a littéralement gagner un nouveau
sens pour percevoir l'univers donc avec
ses ongles ses ondes d'espace-temps qui
se déplace à la vitesse de la lumière et
qui sont produits quand des événements
ultra énergétique comme l'explosion
d'une étoile ultra massive ou alors la
collision entre deux trous noirs où la
collision entre des étoiles à neutrons
donc quand ça se produit à l'autre bout
de l'univers nous on a les instruments
pour le percevoir
et ça c'est absolument remarquable parce
que c'est on a besoin d'eux des
instruments extrêmement précis qui font
plusieurs kilomètres de long et voilà
depuis deux nuls terrain on commence à
détecter ce genre de truc ça fait
littéralement vibrer la terre et ça on
peut le mesurer
c'est des choses qui sont beaucoup plus
petit que le noyau d'un atome qu'en
termes de taille de différence de taille
que ça représente
mais depuis depuis qu'on sait détecter
ça on a une nouvelle fenêtre qui s'est
ouverte sur l'univers et qui me permet
de adam savoir un peu plus sur qu'est ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qui se passe au
delà de ce que nous on se prépare on
veut percevoir je vous à ces faux de
dire que tout ce qu'on sait de l'univers
de sega au delà du ciel finalement c'est
une poignée de trucs que ce soit des
photons soit derrière gosling qui reçoit
soit des neutrinos et novus loisirs les
de cette affaire des sondages nationaux
mais la mode lac 90 95 % de ce qu'on
sait sur l'univers ça reste des images
quoi ça reste des balaurs c'est des
images qui sont pas toujours fait dans
les longueurs d'onde du visible souvent
au delà de ce que nos yeux peuvent
percevoir donc regarder on des rayons x
des ondes radio et à chaque fois qu'on
regarde une longueur d'onde particulière
on va avoir des informations qui sont
différentes parce que chaque processus
physiques et me permets d'émettre de la
lumière dans des longueurs d'onde
spécifiques et elle le fait de combiner
plein longueurs d'onde différentes ça
nous permet d'avoir énormément
d'informations sur qu'est ce qui s'y
passe je sais pas si on prendre la
poussière par exemple ça va absorber des
rayons uv et savard elle
des infrarouges les étoiles dans
l'univers ils vont émettre
essentiellement dans le domaine du
visible mais elles peuvent aussi émettre
dans les rayons gamma si elles sont si
elles sont très très très massives
les explosions des toiles dans l'univers
elles émettent des rayonnements ultra
énergétique aussi faim voilà les ombres
à les ondes radio à nous permettre de
cartographier le gaz dans l'univers
voilà il ya énormément de choses qu'on
peut apprendre de la lumière et depuis
depuis galilée on apprend on apprend
avec la lumière essentiellement quoi
toujours pas fini d'en apprendre grâce
aux images du télescope ou pas pas faire
un jour de passer la photographie soit
on me vois pas faire de neutrinos
craquer ou deux alors fait de la
neutrinos gars alors c'est difficile de
faire le tri nos graphiques je passe ici
aussi le terme est alors pour des rayons
cosmiques au cra pas comment le dire
alors on a les détecteurs de rayons
cosmiques on allait détecteur de
neutrinos 10 trouvent que les neutrinos
c'est très difficile de de les détecter
parce que ça notre sang nous traversent
littéralement il ya des milliards de
neutrinos qui n'ont qui nous traversent
perpétuellement chaque seconde mais on
s'en fout c'est au cesi rien que pour le
prendre et qu'on gère comprendre sans
citer un duo saisir mais par exemple les
neutrinos qui ne viennent de soleil ou
d'ailleurs pour qu'on puisse les
détecter il faut que qu'il traverse
littéralement l'intégralité de la terre
pour que de l'autre côté de la terre
c'est des détecteurs ne puisse détecter
un truc il faut qu'ils passent à travers
6000 km2 de roches en fusion pour
pouvoir arriver sur le pop et hector
pour mourir et voilà c'est un truc de
malade mais c'est ultra dur de détecter
des neutrinos dont l'univers donc les
neutrinos graphie c'est pas pour tout de
suite c'est pas vraiment pour tout de
suite par contre ça pourrait nous
apporter énormément de choses sur suran
sur l'univers par exemple on sait que
aujourd'hui on a une limite à ce que la
lumière
panneaux à prendre sur l'univers parce
que on sait que depuis pendant les 380
premiers milliers d'années après le big
bang l'univers il était opaque c'était
un espèce de brouillard de brouillard
opaque purée de pois quoi on pouvait
rien voir plus loin que le bout de votre
nez et 380 mille ans après le big bang
c'est ss correspond à la création des
premiers atomes donc les électrons qui
se sont mis qui sont collés au noyau
pour la première fois parce que
l'univers était pour la première fois
assez froid donc l'univers à l'époque
380 mille ans après le big bang il est à
3000 degrés donc froid
wade lors de gagner tel point qu'avant
et donc à partir du moment de la
création de ces atomes pour la première
fois donc l'époque ces voiliers pas des
toits il n'y a pas de planète est rien
il ya juste des atomes d'hydrogène et
d'hélium et un peu de lithium et donc
l'univers il devient neutre pour la
première fois parce que les particules
chargées à se sont combinés comme des
aimants pour former des particules notre
unité at home et à la lumière elle aime
bien interagir avec des particules
chargées comme il en trouve plus belle
peut voyager pour la première fois dans
l'univers et l'univers et devient
transparent donc le brouillard il se
lève
sauf que plus on observe de loin dans
l'univers plus on observe dans le passé
et donc il ya une manière un peu un peu
casse tête d'imaginer ça en tant qu
astrophysiciens c'est que on peut pas
imaginer tout ce qui se passe en ce
moment dans l'univers mais on peut
reconstruire l'histoire de l'univers en
regardant de plus en plus loin et on
arrive à un espèce de mur à 380 mille
ans après le big bang
un mur temps spatio-temporelle parce que
lyon regarde loin plus on regarde dans
le passé et on peut pas remonter plus
loin que 380 mille ans après le big bang
en terme de
de distance temporelle quoi tout ce qui
se passe entre le big bang et 380
millions les seules informations qu'on a
c'est nos accélérateurs de particules et
nos théories sur comment les
radioactivité fonctionne comment les
éléments simples secret à des
températures énorme
donc c'est ça de sources d'information
quoi on peut pas au revoir des images de
qu'est ce qu'il se passait pendant les
380 premiers milliers d'années après le
big bang pas de photographier dans tout
ça ouais y'a pas de photographier parce
que l'univers il était juste opaque donc
si on regarde assez loin alors c'est ce
qu'on a fait avec le thé la sonde planck
donc en 2009 on a cartographié la
première lumière émise lorsque l'univers
est devenu transparent
donc ça nous a permis d'avoir des
informations ultra cool sur comment
l'univers a évolué au fil du temps parce
que ça nous a montré que l'univers à
cette époque là c'était vraiment un
brouillard uniforme et isotrope c'est à
dire que dans toutes les directions dans
lesquelles on regardait il s'était
toujours le même brouillard et non ça
nous a permis de conforter dans
certaines idées sur l'évolution de
l'univers par contre tu étais j'espère
contextualiser 7 c'est marrant parce que
du coup vous regardez ça vous dit
je pense qu'on va rien voir rien à voir
cette bo gars se fait à oui c'est un
brouillard
c'est un peu fière qu'on regarde tous
tellement précisément faire donc on peut
retirer des informations statistiques
sur bach et quel genre de quel genre de
brouillard s'était assez rapide à quoi
et on fait si on regarde assez
précisément ce brouillard on voit que il
ya des toutes petites différences de
température genre d'un centaine de
d'un cent millième degré qu'on arrive à
percevoir parce qu'on est des
instruments qui sont absolument badass
télescope planck 1 c'était le point le
plus froids de l'univers jusqu'à jusqu à
un certain moment puisqu'il termine son
dans ses missions donc on sait faire ça
aujourd'hui on a des instruments qui
sont tellement bas d'ascq on peut
détecter des variations d'un sens d'un
cent millième 2 degrés est et on peut on
regarder sur sur ces images les petites
variations de température et ça nous
permet en fait de reconstruire l'état de
l'univers à cette époque là et on peut
utiliser ces informations dans nos
simulations informatiques pour
en tant que condition initiale pour dire
ben on peut se servir de ça comme le
début de nos simulations pour voir
comment les galaxies les évolué et c'est
comme ça qu'on comprend aujourd'hui
l'évolution des grandes structures et
des galaxies avec ceux de cette image là
bas donc complètement homogène et
isotrope ses ouailles cc disons que ça
dépend de l'échelle à la culturiste
situe en garde très très petite échelle
dans termes de densité
tu vas voir des petites fluctuations qui
viennent des fluctuations quantiques du
tout début de l'univers qui ont été
gonflés par l'expansion de l'univers
et l'on peut voir ça c'est un truc que
tu vois mais cette image c'est le truc
le plus vieux qu'on peut observer dans
l'univers aujourd'hui il se trouve que
juste après le big bang il ya d'autres
choses qui ont été créés et notamment
des neutrinos et les neutrinos comme
s'en fout absolument de la lumière que
ça traverse pas d'autre que de la
matière que ça traverse on pense pouvoir
réaliser une espèce de photos du fond de
notre note de tri nos graphiques jeu et
rino graphique il faut foncer dessus
preuve est là je veux remettre ça et
donc on peut potentiellement créer ce
genre d'image qui nous permettrait
d'aller beaucoup plus loin dans de
remonter beaucoup plus loin dans le
temps de faire une espèce de machine à
voyager dans le temps qui nous ramène
380 mille ans avant les 380 mille ans
après le big bang donc à peu près
presque à l'instant de du début de
l'histoire de l'univers tel qu'on le
connaît et ça nous permettrait d'en
apprendre beaucoup plus sur qu'est-ce
que c'était le big bang en pratique donc
donc ça c'est le sait les développements
futurs quoi pour les futures générations
de scientifiques qui seront faire ça ça
ne s'annonce pas simple et ainsi d'y
arriver
franchement j'ai voilà vous avez mon
les prochaines décennies surtout appelé
salai neutrino en neutrino clarifie du
bébé l'univers et je veux voir ça
quelque part et brawn est donc on va
revenir à ta thèse
bordeaux revient m oui pardon donc voila
moi ce que je faisais c'était des
simulations d'image de tennis top avec
tous ces blob tous ces blocs moi ce que
j'avais comme comme simulation numérique
c'était des trucs ultra simple alors
cédé des règles un peu empirique sur
comment comment évoluent les galaxies en
taille en forme en couleur qui ont été
calibrées sur des observations qui
aurait été fait il ya longtemps et ce
que je faisais c'était que j'avais un
simulateur de télescopes donc j'avais
littéralement un simulateur d'univers et
un simulateur de télescopes qui
reproduisait je suis pas le le temps où
les télescopes été ouverts le bruit
qu'on peut voir sur l'image
toutes ces propriétés ou les longueurs
d'onde que le télescope observe et en
fait c'est des vrais propriétés qui sont
calibrés sur les vrais instruments donc
c'est pas facile à reproduire mais on
commence à savoir le faire et ont calqué
sa notre univers simuler qui avec des
lois très physique sur comment les
galaxies elle fonctionne et est en fait
je pouvais comparer les fausses images
avec des vraies images d'une manière un
peu compliqué où on prend des blobs
lumineux rouler on les sélectionne et on
en tire des graphiques sur leur
distribution en lumière en taille etc et
on peut comparer directement les fausses
images et les vraies images et en fait
on a montré que c'était probablement une
des manières les plus fiables
d'étudier comment les galaxies elle
évolue au fil du temps alors ça demande
énormément de puissance de calcul mais
la simulation elle mettait toujours
trois semaines un mois calculé ce qui
était très frustrant pour moi parce que
comme cette méthode qui existent pas
j'ai dû la codé pour coder un truc qui
met trois semaines à faire un test
bah c'est frustrant surtout quand il ya
un bug qui au bout de deux semaines et
demie arrête le calcul et on est obligé
de tout recommencer à être à 7 heures de
cours surpris d'avoir encore des cheveux
et donc voilà c'est ça que j'ai c'est ça
qui m'a occupé pendant trois ans de
développer cette nouvelle méthode et à
bon alors j'ai pas eu le temps de tout
ce que trois ans ces courants vrai j'ai
développé cette méthode
j'ai testé ça sur des cas idéalisé avec
vous j'ai comparé des images simuler
avec les images simulé j'ai montré que
cette méthode elle pouvait fonctionner
dans un cas idéal après le futur alors
c'est pour les prochaines générations
je donnais ma technique aux gens
maintenant à les multiplier
littéralement mais donc et donc voilà
ses successeurs de thèse a probablement
une meilleure méthode pour faire ce que
je fais a bien mieux que ce que je
pourrais faire moi même et après je
crois que je crois que mes descendants
en fait on fait des méthodes un peu plus
fiables maintenant j'ose plus rapide
je pense que dans dix ans tout ce que
j'aurais fait ça servira à grand chose
quoi mais mais c'est pas grave j'ai
appris plein de choses entre temps est
un premier pas dans nos recherches et
puis ça s'est mis lui offrir une vision
c'est ça on ne le dit pas comme une
frustration quoi je sais que les
connaissances qu'ont produit en tant que
scientifiques sont toujours temporaire
de toute manière et il ya une évolution
technique qui est tellement rapide que
c'est difficile de faire un truc qui va
rester fiable avec l'épreuve du temps
quoi ouais mais là on ne pense même pas
tellement la connaissance et puis cela
la technique
les méthodes quoi et qui ça moi je mets
méthode ça implique et de simuler des
centaines de milliers d'univers
différents avec des lois d'évolution
galaxie différents et d'essayer de
retrouver quel univers
il ya bien les big picture un peu mégalo
multiverse n'existe pas mais moi j'ai
ainsi vu juste en ville c'est comme ça
que je vois mais sûrement ses créateurs
d'univers theater d'univers avec
l'astronomie c'est une science qui rend
modestes donc voilà jeanjean simuler des
centaines de milliers ça prenait
beaucoup de place sur les
supercalculateurs et je veux comparer
les à chaque fois chaque univers me
comparer les images on voit l'image et
jean déduisait les quelques et les
univers mais quelle loi reproduisait le
mieux les images qu'on observait
statistiquement parlant
et ça c'est des méthodes qui met
énormément de temps un peu c'est des
trucs un peu standards qu'on appelle des
chaînes de markov
mais voilà maintenant
maintenant on a des probablement des
techniques qui sont qu'ils sont
meilleurs qui commence à être développé
la vôtre tu m'en diras beaucoup plus que
cache que je pourrais en dire sur un sur
ces questions là mais voilà c'est ce que
c'est ce que j'ai fait pendant un moment
et j'ai pu lui parler des chaînes de
markov
les montres mois l'étendue de mon
ignorance la casse et à thèze et
d'autres ça reste ta thèse intitulée
appellerons lui l'introduction 1 21 ans
est interrogé par lui toute la thèse
alors il y avait sûrement des mais bon
on peut quand même le dire dans ta tête
il ya le mot bayésiens tout à fait dubai
jeunes choisissent pas ya voir moi je
les écris ton anglais ma thèse mais
voilà qu'elle mobilise ya quelques mois
la wka pourquoi pourquoi magnifique toi
bon c'est un peu par hasard en fait tout
ce que j'ai à la base on ma
leur balancer dans mon univers de thèse
avec ma question que j'ai mis deux ans à
comprendre ma question quand même savoir
le titre de ma thèse au début de ma
thèse puisque le titre a changé entre
temps
c'était c'est un truc imbitable c'était
qu'au révolution des propriétés
spectrophotométrie des galaxy 2 est
légal de az égal zéro alors c'était
tellement pas sexy que dans la liste des
thèses qu'on va proposer je n'ai même
pas vu et il se trouve que au fil du
temps la vie qui s'est passé et que moi
je me suis retrouvé avec ce sujet de
thèse un peu un peu par hasard dans la
main et en fait quand je les ai lu quand
j'ai lu le résumé le résumé à l'air bien
ça a l'air cool mais mais en fait seul
le titre était pas du tout sexy et j'ai
mis vraiment deux ans à le comprendre
qu'est-ce qu'on attend le titre le titre
c'est inférences de l'évolution
photométrique et en taille des galaxies
aux moyens d'image simulé alors oui
c'est marrant parce que cette cette
thèse est aujourd'hui elle est sûre elle
est sûre elle donc le service ouvertes
des archives de thèse et j'ai regardé
combien de personnes lisent ma thèse des
personnes lille et est généralement est
un genre 700 à 800 personnes qui sont
venues sur le sur la page il y en avoir
cinq cents personnes qui l'ont lu quoi
qu'ils ont téléchargé pour la lire
l'interview télécharger et lire c'est
pas la même chose
oui ben télécharger où on allait et ce à
quoi je pense parce qu'ils ont lu et ça
c'est un verbe je pense qu'il y en a
deux qui l'ont lu mais je suis cette
école de la chaîne mais sébastien
carrasso était entre ending way you lie
mais bon pour ceux qui connaissent mal
l'histoire même ma thèse a été en
trending topics sur twitter pendant mes
soutenant ce que je ne savais pas
pendant ma santé on me l'avait pas dit
du ccc le jeu quand on invite plein de
fluence de thèse est en fait voilà je
suis retrouvé en trending topics
l'europe
devant jour la seule pendant ma
soutenance alors que moi j'étais en
train de me chier dessus a essayé de
vendre la recherche devant un jury donc
voilà j'avais la voix toute tremblotante
et tout et puis à la fin on m'annonce
que sl je savais que tu es en train de
vie non blague c'est vrai c'était un
grand moment et j'ai toujours des gens
que je rencontre aujourd'hui dans des
contextes très différents qui me disent
allez c'est toi le mec de karassou live
c'est un hashtag dit à deux ans les gens
ils s'en souviennent toujours c'est
juste incroyable
si j'ai oublié de surveiller les oublie
je suis pas désolé quand je t'ai
introduit j'ai oublié de mentionner
corning timmons elle est alors je sais
pas si c'est arrivé un jour d'en bas
bamboo de contacts dans d'autres pays
que c'était grave alors je trouve ça
très très bon au moins dans l'histoire
de l'humanité pendant une heure un tweet
soutenance de thèse
j'ai des amis géniaux du coup j'ai pas
vu de corps parle exactement des thèses
déguise bayésiens ont vu comment tu as
pu oublier
j'ai publié sur l'éveil bayésiens donc
envolés la place donc en fait voilà je
mon histoire avec le paysagisme il a
commencé un peu par hasard parce que je
cherchais des méthodes pour comparer des
modèles et des observations et personne
m'a appris ce que c'était le bail à nice
mais dont je suis tombé dessus par
hasard en pataugeant comme on fait
souvent en recherche on patauge pendant
pendant longtemps sur un sujet qu'on
maîtrise pas du tout jusqu'à ce qu'on
tombe sur un article par hasard qu'ils
nous donnent
de par hasard qu'on va lire cet autre
autre article qui va nous donner des
mots clés et en regardant ces mots clés
on sait qu'on découvre qu'il ya toute
une littérature sur le sujet et qu'on
maîtrise pas du tout qu'on va prendre
encore quelques mois pour maîtriser ces
concepts là est un vrai c'est comme ça
que m'est arrivé au bayer à nice mme dia
lui aussi la lecture d'un bouquin que
j'avais commencé à lire s'appelait the
big picture de chaume carroll qui est
moi un numéro intellectuelle aujourd'hui
qui est un physicien au physicien
théoricien qui tient un super podcast
qui s'appelle mindscape dire c'est
vraiment une scène qui vous motive à
faire ce podcast c'est les analogies sur
la forme ces classes mémoire s'est
enlevé un des meilleurs podcasts que je
connaisse aujourd'hui c'est avec le
chien bien cela la flatterie au niveau
des jeunes car la grosse tête et donc
seule carole qui est lui aussi un peu
mégalo de big picture absolument battre
les astrophysiciens qu il aime aussi les
grandes questions et c'est un excellent
livre d'écriture
ouais ouais ce qui développe une espèce
de théories épistémique sur qui
s'appelle le naturalisme poétique où
chaque description on peut voir chaque
description du monde comme étant porteur
d'une réalité mythologique voilà en soi
donc voilà c'est c'est un livre qui m'a
qui m'a pas marqué et c'est la première
fois que j'entendais parler de bail et
ziani sme j'ai entendu aussi julie
agalev qui en parlait dans ses propres
dans ses propres podcaster chaîne
youtube
tu parles beaucoup de jouets guellec
donc je vais pas l'introduire c'est pas
aller voir ça
et voilà ça y est il y avait aussi le
bouquin qu'il quittait beaucoup marqué
je crois qu'elle pèse 2 théorise that
would die je me rappelle plus de
l'auteur par contre sharon mcglade voilà
et qui raconte l'histoire l'histoire la
théorie de baines et comment elle est
appliquée aujourd'hui donc je me suis
pas mal intéressés de sueur sur
l'histoire de dubai zanis j'en ai dédié
un chapitre de ma thèse avec avec ce que
je sais comment ça commence a été
appliquée en physique qui on a le
meilleur chapitre de test de très très
loin
donc voilà ce comme ça que j'ai
découvert le bayer nisme et moi ça m'a
beaucoup aidé dans ma thèse c'est une
approche qui est conceptuellement plus
simple que la proche des statistiques
qu'on m'avait a prises jusqu'à présent
en piste même mais voilà c'est ça
demande énormément de puissance de
calcul pour pouvoir pour pouvoir être
pratique c'est pour ça que en
astrophysique les méthodes bayésienne l
ont pas eu le vent en poupe jusqu'à
jusqu'au début des années 80 on a
commencé à avoir
l'explosion des moyens de calcul où on
pouvait voir la simuler des centaines de
milliers d'univers pour savoir lesquels
sont explique le plus probablement
l'univers qu'on observe dans ce cas on
commence à me tais toi dans tes 90 80 90
à partir des années 90 on commence à
voir part si tu regardes google scholar
tu commences à voir la courbe du nombre
de publications avec les mots béliziens
dans le dans certains articles en
astrophysique commencent à fuser donc
donc voilà aujourd'hui c'est des
techniques qui commence à être standard
donc voilà bienvenue une explosion de
plein de méthodes statistiques dans tous
les cas là pour analyser des données
pour essayer d'en déduire des choses sur
l'univers mais c'est ça qu'on essaye
d'appliquer aujourd'hui et moi ça ne m'a
pas mal servi pour pour ma thèse mais je
me suis servi de deux méthodes un peu
particulières qui ont été développés en
biologie à la base qui s'appelle aller
les méthodes de computation bayésienne
approximative abc abc vrai c'est pas des
méthodes qui sont très très connu outre
à très répandu mais disons que ça aide
bien quand on n'a pas le moyen de mettre
les choses en équation on peut prendre
les données les discret teasé et les
comparer entre elles par des méthodes un
peu un peu un peu difficile à expliquer
sur mer mais voilà c'est des méthodes un
peu un peu freak jeu mais qui commence à
être utilisés quoi expliquer un petit
peu d'écho comme ça mais du covan le
problème c'est qu'en 24 heures de base
est très difficile à appliquer ce sont
de très générales comme en cause du
dénominateur aussi une somme de beaucoup
de choses mais même en cas dans le cas
dans beaucoup de cas en biologie et en
astrophysique et en particulier dans sa
thèse il n'ya pas il ya aussi même le
terme de vraisemblance et profiter des
données sachant à une théorie c'est un
terme très difficile à calculer
je peux imaginer que les théories
théorie de sébastien c'est un mégalo on
peut appeler ça comme ça
les théories de ces registres est pour
faire cesser l'intimidation de l'univers
avec des pop beaucoup de paramètres
compliqué des temps de calcul assez
énorme pour simuler un univers d'ici là
la question ce même pas simuler un
univers c'est étant donné des photos key
a profité que l'univers de sébastien
produit cette photo c'est une question
un peu à la roma
al'inverse parce qu'on est capable de
faire des générer des images mais pour
l'image donnée c'est très difficile de
savoir qui était à profiter que
l'univers de sébastien conduite à cette
photo et du coup donc là même la voix
sont assez difficiles à calculer et du
coup l'idée c'est de la remplacer par
espèce de proxy quelque chose qui a
projeté une approximation de ça et c'est
typiquement ce que fait
c'est merci je l'aï expliqué mieux que
ce que je pourrai jamais l'expliqué donc
merci mais tata pas utilisé à baisser
j'ai utilisé ma part j'ai utilisé une
version un peu modifiée de la bce en
fait il faut savoir que la science à du
bricolage et que les méthodes
statistiques pour pour soi à l'elysée
des données soit en déduire des choses
elles sont utilisées comme un artisanat
il n'y a pas de ya pas de textbook qui
va te dire dans cette situation
utilisent cette méthode doit vraiment se
débrouiller moi j'ai dû me débrouiller
pendant ma thèse pour en savoir
vaval essayer de déduire la pertinence
de temps d'autant qu'approche par
rapport à toutes les approches qui
existe sachant que tu connais pas à 90%
des approches qui existe c'est juste
impossible dumont à un moment tu te dis
bah j'ai cette méthode elle a l'air de
bien marcher en plus j'arrive à la
connaît c'est génial contrairement c'est
aussi comme ça que ça fonctionne la
science n'est pas un petit peu au hasard
qu'on fait pour des raisons pas
forcément très rationnel mais qui
fonctionne plutôt bien dans certains cas
plutôt pas bien dans d'autres
et voilà soir il ya il ya cette
dimension là de la science que je pense
qu'ils méritent d'être mieux connus qui
la galère sa copine c'est 90% de ma
thèse débugger du code on idéalise
beaucoup le travail du de
l'astrophysicien on se dit oh la la
c'est ce poète qui regarde tous les
soirs à travers son télescope de tension
de son télescope l'univers et qui
réfléchit d'une manière complètement
poétique
à sa propre origine et ses annonces et
des gens qui passent 90 % de leur temps
sur des ordinateurs et qui codent et qui
fait qu'il n'arrive pas à cause des
effets sont frustrés c'est incroyable
comme comme truc c'est vraiment ça le
travail de l'astrophysicien aujourd'hui
et on arrive dans une note en fait c'est
ce que ce que je trouve assez génial
c'est qu'on arrive dans une nouvelle ère
de l'astronomie ou on n'a jamais eu
autant de données sur l'univers et on
dans les années à venir
donc dans les années 2020 en particulier
on va avoir une explosion de données qui
va venir de la prochaine génération de
télescopes
alors moi j'ai un objet un chiffre que
j'adore c'est le télé on va qu'on est en
train de construire en ce moment en
australie et en afrique du sud
un amas de radiotélescopes qui s'appelle
ce cas le square kilometre array et
c'est un réseau d'antennes qui va
observer l'univers dans les ondes radio
et à ce truc là ça va produire un
milliard de giga par jour de donner un
milliard de giga par jour c'est un débit
qui est plus important que l'internet
mondial aujourd'hui un milliard par jour
je prévois que sa plus grosse somme
pareille ne se fera pas beaucoup mais
c'est parce que je sais ce que j'avais
su que leur mêlée les auditeurs de faire
un gigaoctet lui a dit un jour 1 1
milliard de giga un lierre de giga
gilles garneau gigue
ok on est de leur dire de gigaoctets ok
les dents ça c'est mon souhait est en
fait on n'a pas les outils pour traiter
toutes ces données ce qui fait qu'on va
devoir développer des algorithmes alors
ça c'est pour la génération actuelle
d'astronomes aujourd'hui cherchent des
moyens de trouver des patterns des
motifs dans des jeux de données qui sont
absolument monstrueux mon grand pour
jeter 90% des données qu'on va accumuler
parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens de les
traquer et pour essayer d'en tirer des
lois sur l'univers à partir de bâle à
deux méthodes baïse ya donc on sait on
sait à peu près à quoi on devrait
s'attendre donc on va plutôt chercher
dans certaines régions plutôt que
d'autres et on va devoir jeter les
autres c'est un peu ce qu'on fait déjà
en
physique des particules le lhc où elles
achètent énormément aussi de donner pour
pour essayer de le plus bas à trouver le
boson de higgs pour trouver des
particules de matière noire etc
mais voilà on arrive dans une galère où
on produit plus de données qu'on peut
les analyser et même couple estos
quelques revues et je trouve ça sont
fascinants quoique on est littéralement
dépassé par l'information qu'on est en
train de produire je sois concerne c'est
c'est vrai qu'ils ont un chien milliards
de collisions par seconde phase comme ça
tebow est quelque chose d engins vrai et
pur sur sur chaque collision ils doivent
connecter des milliers de données tout
poil sont captés par ce ne sont pas si
loin dans des ordres de grandeurs petite
pensée mais c'est faux et après ils
jettent la quasi-totalité de ça parce
que ice hockey
je pense que si on vend sion si on avait
une espèce de mesures de combien de
données scientifiques sont produites
chaque année on arriverait en ce moment
même à une espèce d'explosion des
données qu'on accumule sur l'univers
quoi prêtre même sur les données pas
forcément scientifiques les données en
général bon smartphone qui fondent
pointeau de partout que la croissance de
ça s'est passé beaucoup plus rapide que
la loi nous repasse donc cesser ces
trucs qui vont très très très très très
vite tout est fait ici c'est vraiment ça
et puis bon on peut parler de d'autres
disciplines comme la génétique ou donc
si quantité de données ou même d'autres
d'autres domaines de la biologie
moléculaire analyse des protéines tout
ça au monde la flore intestinale
ristournes je pense qu'il ya énormément
de données qui va sortir de tout ça va
ouais en fait on est en bas j'ai appris
des sciences où j'étais lundi on avait
un historien des sciences qui nous
racontait le rôle des amateurs en
astronomie depuis des années 1800
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
il disait que aujourd'hui depuis les
années 2000
en astronomie on produit plus de données
que les astronomes peuvent les analyser
et du coup le statut de la donner a
changé c'est à dire au lieu d'avoir des
bases de données qui sont jalousement
gardés par des astronomes pour produire
des papiers sur sur les données qu'ils
ont accumulées pendant des dizaines
d'années
ça c'était le statut avant les années
2000 depuis les années 2000 on met ses
bases de données en ligne
donc il ya une grosse culture du libre
les astronomes et du partage de
l'ouverture des données et en fait il ya
des projets de ce qu'on appelle de
sciences citoyennes qui commence à ceux
qui commencent à se développer et qui
sont réunis aujourd'hui sur des
plateformes comme comme universe qui
recense plein de plein de projets de
sciences citoyennes où les gens peuvent
participer à l'effort scientifique à
l'accumulation des données à l'analyse
des données
voilà donc commencer c'est des gens qui
peuvent découvrir des exoplanètes avec
les données du télescope kepler cdag
peuvent classer des images de galaxies
pour savoir si c'était des spirales
ondées ou des ballons de rugby il ya des
gens qui peuvent reprendre des venues
regarder des photos du serengeti pour
pouvoir en déduire la biodiversité c'est
des projets qui sont absolument
fascinant on devrait une fois on peut
passer des heures si on est un amateur
de science mais on peut aussi participer
vraiment à la collecte
l'accumulation des connaissances
humaines quoi aujourd'hui le statut de
la donnée est devenu complètement
différent par rapport à ce qu'il était
il ya vingt ans et puis je pensais aussi
à d'autres domaines comme par exemple
balla meeting où il ya beaucoup de
données
même les comportements des différentes
personnes au quotidien et puis en
sociologie
twitter est une masse de données énormes
mehdi moussaïd récemment interviewé dans
le petit gars et ça ça change la manière
de penser tous ces trucs
et quand il se passe un truc où là on a
beaucoup beaucoup de données maintenant
et le lac de difficultés peut-être petit
à petit ça va être plus l'analyse de
données que la collecte de ces données
white quoi ça fait une problématique qui
va grossir puis sachant en plus que
toutes les méthodes sont compliqués je
crois sur les côtés il est rare cheese
autant on les connaît il commence à y
avoir des package qu'on trouve sur
github afin dé voilà il ya des gens qui
sont assez sympa pour coder des trucs
qu'ils allaient mettre gratuitement à
disposition de la communauté
scientifique et je trouve cela
remarquable je veux dire ma thèse je
n'aurais pas pu la faire par exemple
sans un super service qui s'appelle
stack overflow 4 contre cette espèce de
raie de deux sites où on pose nos
questions d'experts en ligne et on a
d'autres experts qui n'ont rien d'autre
à [ __ ] que de répondre à nos questions
ultra spécifique sur certaines théories
mathématiques certaine manière de koné
un truc c'est c'est un truc de malade
souvent cédé russe je sais pas pour
quelle base que ça veut dire mais bon
j'ai eu des blocages pendant pendant ma
thèse qui ont duré plusieurs semaines
personne peut me renseigner sur tout ça
parce que tu es littéralement à la
frontière des connaissances et il ya peu
de gens autour de toi quelqu'un qui
maitrise ces choses là
ea et tu poses la question qui peut être
très naïve 1 mais qui peut être aussi
très précises sur sur ce site là et deux
jours plus tard tu as cinq types kits
ont répondu avec cinq méthodes
différentes pour répondre à ta question
qui sont toutes pertinentes avec des
références enfin c'est comment est-ce
que ce truc peut exister quoi et je
trouve ça absolument pas pour moi il ya
deux choses sur internet aujourd'hui qui
me font croire en mon pouvoir de
l'humanité c'est wikipédia et stack
overflow quoi
en termes de production de connaissances
c'est une des plateformes qui sont
absolument génial et qui peuvent
accélérer la production de connaissances
comme jamais à quoi
et puis je pense que moi c'est une
question à l'air chaud est encore
ouverte
six mois se poser une question de ma
tempe et c'était je pense à la question
et c'est un prof de maths de
probabilités et j'ai posé la question
alors à tous les après sa double et
mathématicien qui nous écoutent cette
question est toujours ouverte
trois questions d'actu ouverte il a
donné rapidement ces clients-là
réfléchir à ces dames qui laissait
comprend des variables aléatoires
indépendante
l'idée si on veut donc fait on fait la
somme et on sait que les espèces de bois
normal qu'il veuille venir chez galloo
normal c'est la limite infinie mais on
ne peut avoir des bornes pour un nombre
fini de donner on dira c'est quasiment
normal et donc une façon de quantifier
ce qu'on appelait les inégalités de tirs
donc moi je le problème que j'ai c'est
que les inégalités de tirs 9 en gros ça
dit que les déviations sont extrêmes
extrêmes sont vraiment très improbable
et croissent exponentiellement donc
comme la voie normale
et la question qui lui était posée c'est
si on prend juste une tranche vous
regardez juste au lieu de regarder toute
la queue de distribution tous la paix
valu la fin de tout vrai que jusqu'au
bout ces hangars du sme une toute petite
tranche espèce de deux fonctions densité
en fait est ce que ça veut dire
également que s'accroît elle décroît
exponentiellement aussi
proportionnellement largeur de la
tronche quand on voudrait si on est
d'après la loi normale
donc si le coin lecture que je cours je
suis à peu près sûr que c'est vrai mais
ouais apparemment personne n'a voulu
m'aider à le démontrer ça vous avez la
réponse à cette question n'hésitez pas à
l'imposer en commentaires sur les
réseaux sociaux et on remercie les deux
bien que le cinquième mathématicien qui
nous écoutent pour avoir compris cette
question bien une dizaine de personnes
qui ont réfléchi parvient il parle avec
d'autres personnes on espère qu'elle
écoute ce podcast
après le truc c'est qu'il n'y a pas trop
de récompenses que c'était un thème
important d'une preuve que décrivait
mais il se trouve que pour que la
démonstration surveillent déjà bien
d'autres lèvres qu'il fallait prouver en
fait ils étaient faux elles sont je ne
savais pas qu'ils étaient fausses de
faux et je pensais que ea le lem que
c'était le truc le plus important de la
preuve et du coup si quelqu'un de
débloquer ça c'était bon mais bon pas
fait maintenant que je sais que c'est
faux ça moins de valeur fin quand
exactement la question inhabitable mais
en plus mon jeu et franchement il ya des
gens qui répondent à cette question vous
avez mon respect
personnellement vous êtes des héros
voilà il faut être un héros morale pour
répondre à cette question aujourd'hui
lundi si quelqu un procès parce que la
preuve serait sera intéressante face à
une radiothérapie c'est vrai je dis ça
mais je suis en train de me payer palmer
pour les gens qui n'ont pas lu magique
est donc c'est la partie matheuse ou
encore henry est reparti bayésienne
parce que du coup ce qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui est vraiment basée à nantes un truc
qu'est ce qui est vraiment bien en fait
le tout la technique des chaînes de
markov c'est un truc bayésiens en fait
c'est même l'idée c'est de reconstruire
une distribution de probabilités et sa
distribution probabilité c'est en
fonction des données qu'on a et les
données qu'on a c'est des images de
télescopes
quelle est la probabilité de mes modèles
pour reproduire ces données là c'est
littéralement la question à laquelle à
laquelle ça répond ça c'est une
technique bayésienne pour le coup
donc voilà et après on fait des jolies
graff avec tous les paramètres de de mes
modèles qui sont les lois d'évolution en
taille en couleurs et en formes des
galaxies et on est toutes leurs leur
évolution les unes par rapport aux
autres pour voir s'il ya pas des
corrélations caché qui se trouveraient
parmi les paramètres ça si on trouve ce
genre de corrélation c'est sympa par
exemple est ce que la taille d'une
galaxie elle est corrélée à sa forme
est-ce que la couleur d'une galaxie elle
est corrélée à sa taille enfin ce genre
de truc et ça on peut le voir sur les
sur les jolis graphiques que ça fait
mais voilà que c'est le genre de ce
genre de truc que j'ai fait tu te sens
d'expliquer m cmcl cmc ouais c'est sympa
c'est sympa tu as un truc alors il faut
savoir que voilà un modèle c'est une
espèce de code avec des équations qui
vont vous donner des trucs comme des
photographies 10 matchs ils n'ont pas
pas des images qui me laissait juste
c'est les lois d'évolution de galaxy
lors par exemple au fil du temps des
galaxies elles ont tendance en moyenne
évolué en taille avec une certaine loi
de puissance etc et tes couleurs de
galaxies elles vont évoluer selon une
loi que tu as fait 1-1 fit dégueulasse
sûreté sur des données qui date de 20
ans enfin c'est ce genre de truc très
simple vraiment le modèle de deux
modèles quoi un modèle le jeu avec avec
quoi on pourra faire des des mini
univers simuler alors sur simplifiée
évidemment parce qu'on n'a pas si on
devait faire des vrais modèles ça
prendrait beaucoup trop de temps et est
en fait dans on a des paramètres dans
ses modèles qui m'a littéralement des
chiffres qu'on a qu'on met dans ses
modèles qu à cela les lois d'évolution
est ce que c'est plus ou moins pentu par
rapport à ce qu'est ce que t'es tu es
ligne tt droite sont plus ou moins pentu
en fonction en fonction du temps enfin
voila c'est quelles formes prennent ces
lois d'évolution ça c'est des équations
avec des paramètres libre et en fait on
cherche les valeurs de ses paramètres et
comme on les connaît pas à l'avancé on
va aller on va utiliser des techniques
qui se servent du hasard donc il faut
imaginer un espace virtuel qui
correspond à l'espace ce qu'on appelle
l'espace des paramètres ou dans une
dimension alors si on va tout droit on
va faire varier un paramètre de notre
modèle si on va de gauche à droite on va
pouvoir faire varier un autre paramètre
du modèle si on va de haut en bas on va
pouvoir faire varier un autre modèle et
vous imaginez la même chose avec 25
paramètres dont cuba pas de chance non
sur 25 sahara est en fait la technique
des chaînes de markov c'est que vous
avez un espèce de petit robot qui va
partir de n'importe où dans cet espace
là et qui va se balader au hasard une
analogie qui est qui et rigolote c'est
de prendre celui du marcheur bourré
c'est un marcheur bourré sur une colline
qui voit pas parce que il est bourré
donc il a la vision qui est trouble et
il a beaucoup bu donc il marche un peu
au hasard dans ce paysage qui connaît
pas et il va essayer de reconstruire la
forme du paysage et il va avoir tendance
à il va il va essayer de on va lui
donner des lois d'évolution par exemple
s'il descend la colline qu'il est en
train de redescendre on va lui dire non
tu devrais peut-être remonter et donc où
tu devrais tu devrais peut-être rester
là par contre si tu montes la colline
c'est à dire on était plutôt sur le sur
le bon chemin là les l'idée c'est de
trouver le pic de la montagne quoi de
trouver le clip de la colline alors le
paysage est peut être beaucoup plus
complexe que juste une colline il peut y
avoir plein de collines qui sont pas
qu'ils sont dans un espace à 25
dimension donc faut imaginer les
collines quoi et voilà l'idée de ceux de
ce robot de cet homme virtuel bourré
c'est de trouver les maximales les
maxima de ce paysage des deux
de probabilités et ce paysage de
probabilités ça correspond à en fonction
des données qu'on a
la probabilité de notre modèle avec ce
pour expliquer ces données et il se
trouve que c'est vachement dur parce
qu'il peut y avoir plusieurs piques qui
sont à des endroits différents
ça c'est très difficile de les décorer
les prêts on est sur des scénarios
hypothétiques donc on peut se dire que
plusieurs scénarios peuvent reproduire
aussi bien les données qu'on a à l'heure
actuelle donc plusieurs lois de
l'univers pour l'expliquer aussi bien
les images qu'on observe donc pas en
train tout être un petit peu plus de la
technique du coup le le robot est
quelque part à un moment donné donc
c'est presque un certain nombre de
paramètres
as-tu fait des simulations une ou
plusieurs versions d'un univers on en
fait 100 milles à chaque position dure
ou non une position du robot c'est une
réalisation simple quoi donc leur
possible un univers qui correspond aux
paramètres de carrasso c'est çà et là
ils regardent envoyé un certain score
ensuite il tente un pas au hasard
voilà que pas dire civile un autre
univers pour cette rumeur de par mail ru
simule une autre image
c'est ça et je compare cette nouvelle
image à mes données toujours si ça et si
ça colle mieux avec les données qu'avant
on a tu dis c'est cool on a monté il ya
un côté un peu ça existe c'est au
casting du tout parce que ma génération
opératoire n'est ce pas sûr qu'en fait
on apprend à monter mais bon si on a
augmenté ces six celle ci a connu mieux
aux données ont fait le pas on va dire
non on accepte de se balader par contre
si le moins bien avec les données la
simulation précédente
à ce moment là bas toronto on va faire
le va quand même accepter le pas mais j
ai rarement on va voir revenir en
arrière il va tenter un autre pas alors
exactement comme quelqu'un de bourg et
qui essaie de monter une montagne ouais
c'est ça marche aléatoire mais avec un
petit signal de sepa moment-là il y
boëllmann remorque voilà c'est ce qu'on
appelle le lagon
metropolis hasting gens parlent un peu
dans mon livre français qui veulent
aller voir très très bon livre qui cite
la thèse est allée à comme un joli
terrain de la mc mc fait en particules
metropolis à sting qui dit que donc si
on a des bons paramètres et tout ça en
moyenne on va passer pas mal de temps
vers là où c'est plus les modèles sont
plus crédibles et c'est même mieux que
ça en fait là la distribution empirique
de nos positions à travers le temps
correspond à ce qu'on appelle le
postérieur bayésiens ces erreurs qui ont
été balisés 1 sont des gens très très
drôle il cherche les postérieurs à
chaque fois ouais j'ai passé les années
là rires là dessus france jamet grandit
quand tu peux mettre le doigt sur un
coaster walla walla la cebo qu'on ait
dit ça en direct sur un podcast sam
empli de joie et autant ça diminue ma
dignité
autant ça augmente mon bonheur très bien
de choses à dire sur ta thèse je suis
encore parce qu'ils soient dans ce
domaine n'a plus vraiment en fait
à partir du moment où j'ai arrêté ma
thèse je me suis un peu bas j'ai
vraiment arrêter la recherche en fait je
me suis consacré à la vulgarisation à
temps plein j'ai profité de ce
merveilleux système qui s'appelle le
chômage pour pouvoir me lancer dans des
projets que qu'il attendait depuis enfin
qui me trottait dans la tête depuis
maintenant depuis plusieurs plusieurs
années alors cinq ou six ans et du coup
je me suis plutôt concentré sur des
choses qui ne traitent pas de
l'évolution des galaxies
lorsque ben voila j'ai passé trois ans
sur les galaxies les galaxies risque pas
de changer vraiment dans dix prochaines
années vont j'espère si elle change
c'est pas très loin s'approche de la
force du fonds de manière inquiétante
mais voilà ce
je me suis plutôt concentré sur d'autres
aux sciences d'autres d'autres papas pas
forcément de l'astrophysique d'ailleurs
c'est plutôt les intérêts du moment quoi
les mecs et toutes les choses qui sont
pas de l'astrophysique mise au placard
article sur l'astrophysique je m'y
intéresse surtout pour en faire des
vidéos aujourd'hui
on pourra suivre sur ma chaîne sur
d'autres chaînes j'ai aussi bossé avec
string theory pendant un bateau aussi
d'ailleurs pendant pendant un an et bon
voilà c'est plutôt c'est plutôt là
dessus que je vais je me forme sur
d'autres sciences aujourd'hui quoi c'est
sam et intérêts du moment là je pense
qu'on va en parler mais je le propose si
ça doit de parler d'avoir d'avoir cela
d'un peu de vulgarisation l'intérieur
vulgarisateur hors pair si j'ai un papa
et doux qui terrasse et à ses
allégations depuis un petit bout de
temps quand c'est en fait la
vulgarisation je commençais à
m'intéresser à partir du moment où j'ai
découvert carl sagan parce que carl
sagan c'est quand même le vulgarisateur
par excellence il a peut-être plus fait
pour la vulgarisation que n'importe qui
depuis les deux des deux derniers
siècles et il ya vraiment eu un impact
énorme dans la diffusion de la culture
scientifique en général et en fait il ya
une espèce de flambeau d'inspiration que
j'essaye de reprendre parce que lui il
m'a inspiré à voir le monde de manière
scientifique et je me suis dit que cette
vision la balle et c'est une espèce de
mission une mission sacrée
ça fait un peu aux missionnaires
chrétiens de gaza qui a converti va donc
tu as cherché à commercialiser marché à
convertir des gens là et ce n'est pas
forcément à les convertir parce que
délicat des choses au delà du domaine
scientifique arleux le domaine
scientifique par la vision du monde
scientifique elle est quand même assez
limité mais il ya aussi d'autres
manières de voir le monde qui peuvent
être aussi riche culturellement et je
suis à fond je suis à fond là-dedans je
veux dire j'adore 10 mythes de création
sociologie ethnologie anthropologie part
je trouve
il ya une vraie richesse à diffuser ce
genre d'histoire qui viennent du monde
entier
mais la science à ce statut un peu
particulier qui fait que non seulement
c'est une approche plutôt rigoureuse
pour comprendre le monde mais en plus
cette approche elle est belle donc
voilà ça à partir du moment où j'ai
découvert qu allissa gagnent et qui m'a
inspiré énormément à voir l'univers de
cette manière là j'ai eu envie de
transmettre cette vision là d'autres
gens et depuis ben voila j'ai fait plein
de trucs j'ai commencé par un blog que
j'avais tenu depuis que j'ai fini ma
prépa jamais participé à un concours de
vulgarisation quand j'étais en troisième
année de licence
j'avais faire un article sur
l'intrication quantique alors ses deux
premières années où je faisais de la
mécanique quantique qui va de toute ma
vie je me dis allez je vais me lancer
dans un article de vulgarisation sur
l'intrication quantique
c'était risqué aujourd'hui je lis cet
article et je me dis oh ça va ya encore
des trucs qui se tiennent en plus juste
leurs textes
j'ai pu quand même bien bien bien citer
mes sources à attaquer l'année ça
c'était vivaces vidéo c'est bastia corse
à côté sur ses doigts jusqu'à 3 et après
il a dit je sais plus je sais pas
est-ce que c'est pas le truc le plus
physicien que j'ai jamais fait ça va
faire six et ont maintenant sept huit ou
parce que c'est de moi j'ai commencé à
blogger 2012
waze est en 2012-2013 passe comme ça
c'était un peu la paire d2 je pense
qu'il ya des blogueurs quand on sait le
blogueur peut commencer à peut-être un
peu avant toi c'était vraiment l'époque
de l'explosion des blogs
il n'y avait pas beaucoup de blogs
scientifiques à l'époque il a fait des
sciences qui commençait à émerger
et voilà j'ai commencé avec des articles
où je mettais à peu près tout ce que
j'apprenais
avec cette vision un peu un peu poétique
politique aux scientifiques du monde
enfin je mettais des poèmes que je renie
aujourd'hui voilà ce genre de truc quoi
tu vois c'est d'abord le blog il
s'appelle le senso phocéenne thunder a
claqué puisqu'à jusqu'à le début de la
chaîne youtube il existait toujours
aujourd'hui il ya il est un peu mort
jamais l'église mais ils disent tous
leurs efforts pour sortir c'est ce sas a
cité directement et sa voix la cc du
dossier m mais en vrai j'aimerais bien
reprendre reprendre le blog parce que
l'écriture c'est quelque chose qui me
plaît qui me plaît plus que la vidéo au
final dans mon activité préférée quand
je fais de la vidéo c'est vraiment
décrire en fait là pas de tourner et de
monter c'est de décrire et j'aime
beaucoup cette ce format là c'est un
format qui perd un peu en popularité
avec la montée des vidéos etc donc donc
au final j'ai plus d'impact quand je
fais une vidéo que quand je quand
j'écris un article de blog qui sera lu
par 400 personnes
mais il ya ce côté un peu plaisir de
de mettre les choses à plat de mettre
des chiffres et d'aller aussi loin qu'on
veut dans la réflexion et ça j'aime
beaucoup je préfère écrire les vidéos
que l'étendue ouais mais sa puce un
pactole une fois que je les ai souvent
dénoncé comme marc et de rajouter à la
partie du tournage et quelques blagues à
l'oral elle passe plus que les blagues
alors que sané pour mes blagues verrait
que tu veux pas t'entendre dire
certaines blagues que je veux pas dire
les pièces au pire que mettre le doigt
sur le poster mais il faudrait un jeu
objectifs des blagues mais bon voilà
donc j'ai commencé par un blog ensuite
j'ai j'ai lancé un une association pour
la promotion de la culture scientifique
qui s'appelle le collectif conscience
comme gênant ce après une après-midi de
déprime où je regardais l'état de la
télévision l'état de la science à la
télévision et j'ai vraiment déprimé ce
jour là et je me suis dit waouh il faut
qu' il faut qu'on se lève tous ensemble
citoyens pour répandre la culture
scientifique dans le monde entier ça a
plutôt bien marché
ça fait cinq ans que ça existe
maintenant le collectif conscience on a
fait pas mal de projets de projette que
de cul pour diffuser la culture
scientifique on a fait un compte twitter
qui s'appelle en direct du labo où
chaque semaine on a un chercheur ou une
chercheuse différents qui prend les
rênes du compte et qui raconte son
parcours qui raconte qu est-ce que c'est
son métier de chercheur et chercheuse au
quotidien et c'est quoi son domaine on a
toutes les sciences
possible de la physique de la bio de
l'informatique des sciences humaines et
sociales
on essaie de mettre un accent sur la
parité et des intervenants et des
intervenantes aussi et de tous les
niveaux de pouvoir pour essayer de
donner c'est un espèce de portraits de
qu'est-ce que c'est la recherche en 2019
donc pour pc de de briser cette image du
savant fou et c'est quoi la remplacer
par une image d'un programmeur qui
déplogue accès direct par les chercheurs
en blouse blanche il en existe vraiment
et le mcs maintien qui à la craie et le
maximum c'est vrai ce 21e solution est
donc voilà ça c'est un des nombreux
projets qu'on a qu'on a lancé on avait
lancé un magazine de vulgarisation qui
s'appelle c'est phallus aussi une espèce
de moteurs de recherche qui cherche dans
la blogosphère scientifique francophone
pour répondre à la question comment
chercher des infos fiables en français
sur les six ans donc on a essayé de
faire des choses est donc aujourd'hui on
fait aujourd'hui quelques quelques
nouveaux projets qui sont qui sont en
cours et ouais probablement en cours de
financement un jour mais c'est aussi un
investissement personnel et financier
beaucoup beaucoup de ma part et de la
part de certains membres de
l'association avoir la neutralité
économique sur ce genre de projet quand
on est militant
c'est une forme de militantisme pas
c'est pas simple donc
donc pour l'instant on est on en est là
chercher chercher des sous pour essayer
d'avoir
d'avoir un minimum d'impact même si
certains projets ont déjà des impacts
mais qui sont juste dû à l'implication
des membres de l'association
je pense qu'on pourrait avoir plus
d'impact si on avait plus de sous mais
voilà ça c'est ce que j'ai c'est ce que
l'on a lancé en 2015 qu'il était
président de cette association je sais
pas je suis dictateur de l'assaut de vie
depuis cinq ans maintenant
l'accord est président ça watts et sa co
fondateur parce que voilà jean selles ou
même le concept mais après on a on s'est
réuni aujourd'hui on compte quelque
chose comme 80 membres dans
l'association et on essaie de on essaie
de faire des trucs avec avec des bric et
de broc mais pas d'ipad et henri broch
le cas des jeux comme des pouvoirs de
dictateur s'est passé lorsque cette
requête je regrette donc voilà ça ça
existe et donc est donc depuis depuis
2000 15 depuis quatre ans et deux jours
au moment où on enregistre ce podcast
je me suis lancé dans là dans la vidéo
au début je pensais faire ça tout seul
naïvement et puis j'ai été rejoint par
mes grands amis maintenant qu'ils
s'appellent etienne le dolley qui est
journaliste scientifique et qui m'a
proposé son aide sur le projet aki
devenu le senso fondeur plus tard la
série donc la chaîne youtube où on
essayait de l'idée de base c'était de
faire un cosmos à la française
cosmos de carl sagan avec moins de
moyens et avec sur youtube 0 au budget
j'ai investi 1000 euros dans du matériel
qui est toujours le matériel avec lequel
je tourne aujourd'hui et j'espère que ça
va changer bientôt parce qu'on n'a pas
le matériel qu'on a qu'on voudrait avec
les ambitions qu'on a pour pour la
chaîne on a fait des demandes du cncr et
sa mort on repassera traite dans les
doigts pour investir en une du meilleur
matériel est là et voilà c'est ça un peu
explosé parce que j'ai lancé ça en 2015
c'était en première année de thèse alors
je me souviens de un moment d'anthologie
où je mets une réunion avec les
directeurs de thèse et je viens de
sortir mon premier épisode et je suis
tout fier de moi
et j'arrive dans le bureau pour la
réunion hebdomadaire et j'arrive je suis
tout fier vous avez vu j'ai fait j'ai
commis ce si je le rencontre montpellier
épisode et je le vois qu'il ya des têtes
d'enterrement
je me sens non mais c'est bon t'as pas
fini tes conneries n'a que faire de la
science c'est pour ça qu'on est là je
suis sorti la tête baissée et à partir
de ce jour là j'ai jamais arrêté de leur
dire que ce que ce que je faisais mais
j'ai continué à le faire quand même
j'ai mené une espèce de double vie
pendant ma thèse ou le jour je faisais
je faisais ma thèse la nuit je faisais
ma thèse et nous le la nuit je faisais
aussi que sa seconde
donc c'était dans ce c
deux courses parce que les deux
activités sont quand même un peu
chronophage
j'ai pensé que du coup lité parce que tu
avais l'air très content tu pensais côté
directeur à être content de bah ouais
parce qu'en fait j'avais à cette époque
j'avais vraiment cette impression cet a
priori que la vulgarisation
c'est considéré comme le travail d'un
chercheur de base mais il se trouve que
en pratique c'est vraiment une question
de génération les la vulgarisation ça
commence à intégrer la culture du monde
académique on a des trucs comme fight of
sound qui commencent à conquérir le
monde et voilà et on voit un
enthousiasme des jeunes chercheurs pour
pouvoir communiquer la science et c'est
vraiment beau à voir quoi n'a cessé de
cette mission d'aider des jeunes qui
essaient de d'inspirer d'autres d'autres
d'autres gens et de mettre la science
dans le débat public
mais pour les vieux chercheurs qui ont
encore cette vision très la recherche
s'est tu passes toute ta vie à faire de
la recherche et parfois tu passes 40 ans
sur une question et tu pendant 40 ans à
tous les colloques académique qui va
poser la même question jusqu'à ce que
l'on finisse par se partagent répondre
ou par dire que cette question n'était
pas pertinente depuis 40 ans donc et
pour ça donc pour beaucoup de gens et en
astrophysique en particulier ccsa à
l'astrophysique et ça s'arrête là et le
travail du chercheur s'est pas d'aller
mettre de la science dans le débat
public et s'est pas encore valoriser
autant que je le voudrais dans le monde
académique
en tout cas ça l'était pas pendant
pendant la tête parce que j'ai pas
défendre un peu traité était directeur
de recherche mais si moi j'étais
sinon chercheurs attention je sais pas
trop mais enfin gagner des postes où
tant de stocks par exemple si j'étais en
tinner traque professeurs mais pas
titulaire il voit un étudiant de test de
première année qui vient ne parlait que
de vulgaires bassiste avait déjà vu
éclaire un article les autres
connaissent et si j'avais le blog est
donc un outil de recherche non non j'ai
fait un article de recherche pendant
toute ma thèse ça a pris deux ans et
demi voilà mais je vais un premier
incident de première année de thèse en
se lançant des trucs comme ça la vulgate
château chinon gilles massa le temps je
vais pas a jugé le directeur de thèse
dans les dix était adorable j'ai
franchement j'ai vu j'ai pris j'ai vécu
une bonne thèse quoi je connais plein de
gens qui ont vécu une mauvaise thèse moi
j'ai vécu une très bonne thèses et les
voilà mes director ces thèmes et mémé
deuxième part en quoi est il faisait ça
pour mon bien ça c'est clair tête et je
le deuxième par an le 1er mai pas on est
les premiers c'est mes parents ils te
carl sagan il est où dans tout ça haquin
sagan ces moments si oui bon d'accord ça
oui mais je suis en voilà
un bébé voilà être je comprends que
c'est pour mon bien pour le bien de ma
carrière académique qui faisait ça on
veut pas pour ça non plus sur le coup ça
a fait mal agi mais mais après après
j'ai bien pris je veux dire c'est normal
et c'est rationnel de leur part de
vouloir me guider vers quelque chose de
plus académique parce que quand tu vis
une carrière académique t'as intérêt de
publier un maximum d'intérêt de de
produire la meilleure recherche possible
ou alors le plus de recherches possibles
c'est pas forcément la même plus là mais
voilà ce que je voulais au début de ma
thèse c'était de continuer dans une
recherche académique et je me suis rendu
compte au milieu de ma thèse que j'avais
plus de plaisir à produire à produire de
la vulgarisation et à diffuser les
connaissances plutôt que de produire des
nouvelles connaissances et il trouve que
j'étais meilleur à ça aussi donc ça joue
et donc
donc voilà c'est au final ma carrière
c'est de la vulgarisation donc je suis
content de ne pas avoir écouté mes
directeurs de thèse
mais je comprends leur décision quoi
c'est quand même pas évident mais cissé
c'est déjà tout un système de
valorisation du travail
des chercheurs qui le gard isation alors
je crois que c'est elodie à qui misait
jodie chabrol qui dit qu'il me disait
que par moments dans les demandes de
financement anr il y a wen partie ça
commence à arriver ça même norme dans
les projets de recherche européens les
oeufs rca etc
on commence à avoir une partie
vulgarisation mais de médiation
scientifique qui commence à prendre une
place importante je sais pas mais une
place dans les dossiers de financement
ou de subventions et or et c'est cool
c'est vraiment cool
après ça peut avoir l'effet inverse
d'obliger certaines personnes qui
veulent pas du tout faire ça à le faire
et de parts d'être contre-productif dans
ce genre de truc parce qu'au final quand
on donne de l'argent pour faire de la
science c'est aussi pour faire de la
science
donc il fut mitigée face à ce genre de
la proche ok rien il ya un changement de
culture à aborder avant le changement de
compensation économique
enfin moi tout ce que j'ai fait en
vulgarisation pour moi ma thèse je les
fait bénévolement en fait j'aurais pu
faire des choses qu'il était rémunéré
pendant ma thèse généralement les choses
qui sont valorisés c'est donner des
conférences aux cayes la découverte
faire des animations dans des écoles etc
et j'ai sciemment décidé de faire autre
chose parce que je pensais que ça aurait
plus d'impact et abba a posteriori bas
j'avais raison je suis content de
l'avoir fait mais c'était un effort
bénévoles quand je n'aurais pas pu le
faire payer pour pour faire ça donc
donc voilà mais après je commence à voir
aussi les limites du bénévolat
parce que quand tu veux faire des trucs
qui ont un impact il faut aussi des sous
bon pour mettre à l'échelle ce que tu
fais à petite échelle de se
professionnaliser un petit peu pour
vraiment faire ça bien et prennent le
point de dégager du temps
ouais voire même avoir des
collaborateurs du matériel aussi
exactement pied non j'ai aussi je
commence à voir la porte
qu'est-ce que bien manger c'est lé 10
août je pense que c'est plus haut
vulgarisateur de faire le gars isation
puisque chercheurs ben ça dépend en fait
je n'ai pas de réponse monolithique
elle a donné ça dépend ça dépend
vraiment je pense que tout le monde
enfin en fait je pense que vraiment tout
le monde peut partager les sciences les
exemples de réussite totale de ces
docteurs doses mais n'y a pas une
formation très scientifique de base mais
qui a le plus d'impact en vulgarisation
scientifique aujourd'hui chez chez les
jeunes et je trouve qu'il fait un
travail admirable quoi la plupart de ces
épisodes
il a su exploiter le système youtube
pour pour avoir des millions et des
millions de vues à chaque fois et ça
marche
et il parle de science et il rend les
gens plus curieux qu'ils étaient avant
et plus de valeur aux sciences et je
trouve ça admirable et donc je pense pas
qu'il faille être scientifique pour
pouvoir bien vulgarisé surtout que les
infos elles sont et sont là ils sont sur
internet il faut juste avoir une idée un
peu rigoureuse qu'est ce que c'est de
trier des informations ils disposent de
techniques journalistiques à acquérir
pour croiser les sources pour pouvoir
déterminer
qu'est-ce qui est fiable qu est-ce qui
est pas fiable c'est pas facile mais ça
se fait mais il ya aussi le fait de bien
s'entourer de faire relire ses scripts
seuil et des bonnes pratiques coiffic
qui mérite d'être d'être promu qui sont
bien promues au café des sciences où on
se fait relire mutuellement de noscript
mais voilà je pense que les chercheurs
mériterait plus vulgarisée les citoyens
émérites réa plus s'intéresser aux
sciences et parfois même à vulgariser
selon selon leur niveau et ce qu'ils
veulent ce qu'ils veulent propager comme
idée et je pense que si l'on marche tous
main dans la main et on qu'on fasse une
grande chaîne de l'amitié
tout autour de la terre on en arrivera
un monde et voilà c'est très très
pragmatique c'est peut être pas du tout
idéalisé qui n'aborde donc un peu
idéaliste
je crois qu'on est dans une époque
vachement pessimistes en fait que ce
soit sur l'avenir sur notre société sur
notre espèce en général une espèce de
deux cultures du human bashing parfois
la raison et parfois à tort et et on en
fait voilà je pense que c'est pas cinq
hommes comme le christ comme comme
l'esprit du temps je pense qu'on a on a
besoin d'avoir une vision du futur et de
notre impact sur le monde qui on doit
vouloir vouloir prendre non seulement
préservé préserver notre monde préserver
nos sociétés préserver notre planète
mais aussi avoir une idée de là où on
veut aller collectivement et pour ça il
faut rendre une certaine vision
désirable et sg ça ça je le vois pas par
exemple dans le débat public
enfin je vois peu selon les groupes
idéologiques qui prouvent ce genre
d'idée cd
très différentes et pas forcément basée
sur les sciences du monde ou d'un futur
souhaitable donc donc ouais je pense
qu'on a besoin d'une vision d'un futur
souhaitable avant de construire sa
future là parce que sinon bah sinon on
risque pas d'avoir un monde meilleur
quoi et on veut tous un nombre d mais on
a tous des critères différents de ce que
c'est un manque d'ailleurs et pas
forcément une mauvaise chose mais
parfois il ya des contraintes physiques
qui font que ça serait bien d'avoir une
vision un minimum partagé quoi des
données aussi envie de donner un ouais
c'est ça ouais mec juste dans le rejet
des choses qui vont pas ouais il ya
david attenborough d'ailleurs que dit à
ce sujet alors il lui a dit en anglais
mais si want to make them acte i would
have to make them girls est donc si tu
veux les faire agir il faut qu' il faut
qu'ils s'en foutent pas quoi enfin c'est
pour ça que voilà les détruire des
documentaires de davie est une bourse et
c'est généralement peu de science mais
beaucoup d'animaux mignons pour dire
voilà ces animaux mignons et
disparaissent et saha que ton cerveau
pour te dire un an la nature elle
disparaît vite il faut que j'agisse part
il ya des limites à sa évidemment mais
mais c'est une approche que moi qui me
parle parce que ça utilise les motions
pour pouvoir créer une action positive
josé huguette aussi qu'ils disaient si
vous voulez années les gens à construire
un radeau pour les prendre l'eau s'ils
en ne leur expliquer pas comment faire
le bateau dans un premier temps on va
essayer de leur donner envie d'aller
j'adore jouer au golf
mais cette situation elle et d'antoine
de saint-exupéry allez y donc elle l'a
peut-être citer qu'elle a cédé à ses
avances idée en tant que fan de
saint-exupéry
car ça y est
[Rires]
du coup asséné sense of wonder quand
vous êtes rencontrés et ben en fait on
s'est rencontré sur le projet c'est
quelqu'un que le coffret etienne qui
fait des vidéos avec moi depuis
maintenant quatre ans je en fait je
pensais vraiment faire ça tout seul au
début et en fait j'ai comme je
connaissais rien en vidéo j'ai commencé
à un probable à faire des appels sur les
réseaux sociaux en mode
bonjour ce serait quoi une bonne caméra
selon vous pas trop pourri pour prendre
de la vidéo et du son parce que j'ai un
projet audiovisuel que j'aimerais
réaliser et donc là et il a débarqué
dans mes dormait mention et dormait dans
mes messages et le suivi sur twitter de
base et il m'a fait la salut c'est moi
je vais dans une école de journalisme
et là j'ai des projets à fort d'année
enfin j'ai du temps libre
j'aimerais bien m'investir dans un
projet de vulgarisation le tiens il me
entre une chose bien est ce que ça dit
qu'on se rencontre pour voir ce qu'on
peut faire ensemble donc on a fait on
est parti dans un bar et on a expliqué
nos visions respectives et se trouve qu
on était vachement alignés et c'est le
début d'une belle aux brumes ans il
était grand de remembrement s'est dit
youtube francophones et y te voir
ailleurs alors c'est au même au même
titre que que toi et mathieu fille voilà
on a une portable ça se compare pas si
possible mais derrière nous mais on
s'égare sa blessure de kadir ne veut pas
dire il est où jésus et du coup c'est
une seconde heure ça rapporte beaucoup
tune
c'est rapporte précisément 462 et de 470
euros par mois qu'on divise par deux et
qu'il ya des mois donc pour l'instant ça
suffit ça y est mon loyer
merci lemercier le chômage et merci aux
70 type piper qui finance qui finance la
chaîne dans ça aide à payer des voyages
des déplacements pour pouvoir les faire
sur des lieux de tournage etc
pour l'instant ce n'est pas assez pour
que gens vivent de manière viable est en
jeu commence à arriver à la forme au
chômage et non en octobre
donc je commence à voir l'échéance donc
j'essaie d'accumuler un peu des sceaux
pour pouvoir continuer les projets que
je fais jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à ce que
j'ai déjà j'ai terminé mes projets et
après que je passe à autre chose
peut-être dans ma vie le projet est en
ce moment un bouquin que j'écris depuis
maintenant deux ans et qui sortira
l'année prochaine
et donc voilà c'est pour l'instant je ne
vis pas de la chaîne
autant que je le voudrais mais j'ai bon
espoir parce qu'on a pas mal de projets
sur la chaîne qui vont commencer à
arriver
j'ai tourné un documentaire des quelques
mois qui devrait sortir d'ici quelques
semaines sur sur le senso fondeur un
documentaire sur le changement
climatique parce que c'est un sujet qui
me touche
on a alors gardons ouais on a on a
commencé à faire essayer de faire
financer avec le cnc une série en quatre
épisodes qui va traiter des liens entre
science et science fiction qu'on
aimerait reproduire avec avec les gens
qui font string theory où on irait dans
des dans des lieux différents pour
pouvoir parler de ses liens là comment
les comment les auteurs de sf
investissent les connaissances de leur
époque
comment ils inspirent eux mêmes les
chercheurs qui part parfois deviennent à
leur tour des des écrivains de science
fiction sont pas au trot s'est
spécialisée astro espaces donc on va
parler de la fusée de tintin on va
parler
on va parler de carl sagan on va parler
de communication la caisse d'alien un
top voir là on va parler de l'ascenseur
spatial on va parler de deux langages de
langage universel pourparlers avec des
aliens enfin ce genre de ce genre de
sujet si ses finances et évidemment pour
l'instant ça va on croise très très fort
les doigts mais ça nous permettra aussi
d'acheter du meilleur matériel pour
pouvoir avoir des meilleures images du
meilleur sont surtout du meilleur son et
de payer de payer des artistes qui font
des animations pour faire ce qu'on veut
faire quoi part je m'intéresse pas mal à
comment est-ce qu'on peut raconter des
histoires de manière différente et
comment on peut promouvoir les sciences
en vidéo parce que je pense que le
médium vidéo a pas encore épuisé son
potentiel en tant que diffuseur de
messages dans la société
on est au tout début du truc un même si
la hype de la vulgarisation française
sur youtube et commencer à retomber un
petit peu on est quand même sur le ton
début de ce qu'on peut faire en tant que
vidéaste je pense qu'il ya une richesse
à explorer les différentes manières
raconter des histoires et j'essaie
d'utiliser cette chaîne comme un comme
un terrain d'expérimentation de
storytelling d'essayer des formats
différents et pour l'instant les types
heures me permettent en tout cas
partiellement de consacrer mon énergie à
ce à quoi la créativité à créer de
nouvelles histoires pour promouvoir la
science de différentes manières ok mais
du coup dur en termes de ressources de
revenu battu mise surtout sur youtube je
mise en fait je vais surtout sur des
partenariats institutionnels
j'essaie de faire en sorte de promouvoir
des vidéastes pas juste moi même les
vidéastes francophones qui font du très
bon travail pour qu'ils puissent se
maquer avec des
avec des institutions scientifiques
respectable et donc là par exemple le 8
juin lui la nuit du 8 juin prochain on
va faire une affaire douze heures de
live sur domaine
ça va être notre deuxième live toute la
vie et en fait c'est un premier temps il
ya quelques jours le procure le coude et
donc le sel la nuit du samedi 8 juin
jusqu'au dimanche 9 juin on va faire de
douze heures de conférence enfin une
nuit blanche de l'astronomie c'est à
l'occasion des 80 ans du cnrs et donc
vont forcir labo donc le mastic et
d'astrophysique de paris m'a proposé de
de retransmettre en direct cet évènement
sur ma chaîne pourquoi pas d'accord ou
pas été trop deux thèses n'ont pas été
trop fâché d'être au travail des mineurs
non non on regarde de très bons donc
voilà ça va être une expérience parce
que ça s'est jamais fait avant je vois
ma connaissance de faire de ce lien
entre des chaînes personnel et puis de
la communication un peu plus
institutionnelle alors évidemment si on
fait ça c'est qu'on a confiance dans ce
qui va être dit et conseils que ça va
être une bonne manière de promouvoir
l'astronomie il y aura des gens comme
roland lehoucq
miho janvier bon vulgarisateur qui
seront là donc c'est aussi pour ça moi
personnellement j'ai plutôt excité à
cette idée que d'animer cette nuit là
mais après l'idée c'est d'aller plus
haut on travaille avec des institutions
plus il y aura des sous qui vont être
débloqués pour des vidéastes pourront
voir parce que c'est pas les
institutions elles cherchent des
nouveaux publics et atteinte à lancer
leurs buts aussi enfin tout cas pour
pour les labos qui veulent le faire et
les vidéastes le cherche un modèle
économique plus stable donc
donc il ya clairement quelque chose à
travailler à ce niveau là donc voilà il
y aura peut-être d'autres choses avec
bientôt avec d'autres institutions que
je vais pas donner maintenant parce
qu'il n'y a rien de rien de fait mais
voilà c'est plutôt par là que j'aimerais
me professionnaliser
j'aimerais bien aller aussi vers le
documentaire et voilà le premier
documentaire que j'ai que j'ai réalisé
là qui sort dans quelques semaines ce
qui n'est qu'une minute
une expérience qui va vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup plus et j'aimerais vraiment
retenter l'expérience pour faire des
choses un peu ambitieuse en termes de
mise en scène en termes de lieux dans
lesquels on va en termes de comment
raconter des histoires
si l'univers me laisse faire des formats
un peu long pour raconter certaines
histoires et avec des plus gros moyens
je suis carrément chaud quoi donc
et surtout avec une grosse production
derrière enfin avec toutes les
contraintes que cela impose une course
production mais mais comme on est sur le
web il ya une liberté créatrice qui les
plus plus plus ouverte plus libre que
qu'à la télé par exemple c'est vraiment
complètement bouché
et plus j'entends parler de la télé - ça
me fait envie sur le web
je pense qu'il ya les documents web vont
avoir le vent en poupe l'eau d'ici
quelques années
riquet j'espère que tu as quand même
fait des collaborations avec des
institutions
quand je pense à la bio science ouais
alors j'ai fait un truc avec byd aux
sciences à leur vie de science c'est
destiné aux enseignants
à la base c'est vrai ça a été lancé par
david aux âpres et la fondation la main
à la pâte et l'idée c'est de faire des
vidéos à destination des enseignants qui
voudraient faire des activités de
sciences avec leurs élèves mais qui
n'ont pas d'idée de quoi faire ça peut
être ça peut être un peu un peu
paralysant en tant que prof prof de
primaire autre prof de collège de bâton
on a envie de partager la science mais
on sait pas trop
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire et
surtout il y en a qui sont pas du tout
formés aux questions scientifiques donc
il ya un côté psychologique était de
barrières qui les empêche de faire ça et
l'idée de vidéos science c'était de
faire c'est toujours ce que ça existe
toujours de de fournir un espèce de base
de données alors là il se trouve que la
fondation la main à la pâte à une énorme
base de données d'activités
scientifiques pour des profs
enfin pour les enseignants qui n'est
quasiment jamais lui parce que c'est me
de manière très basse et un site quoi
c'est très difficile à voir et accéder
aux ressources etc
et l'idée c'est de mettre ça en vidéo
avec non seulement des vidéastes qui
vont faire des
des activités qui vont proposer des
idées d'activités mais qui vont fournir
un recul scientifique sur qu'est-ce qui
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ses
activités pour répondre aux questions
que les élèves pourraient avoir sur ce
sujet et à quand j'ai vu ça j'ai dit wow
trop coulé tout c'est un super projet
tout le monde et rip donc tout le monde
est toujours alité du relais qui marche
très très bien
et voilà que c'est un projet qui semble
qu'il ya un impact un peu différent des
projets que je fais habituellement parce
que quand je travaillais sur les
chasseurs fondeur tu vois le nombre
d'abonnés donc voilà on touche on va
toucher aux 50000 personnes directement
sans vie de personnes 310 personnes
parfois dans les meilleurs des cas et là
on est sur une chaîne qui est plus petit
parce que ça touche plus de niche
voilà c'est cd vidéos qui sont vus
quelques milliers de fois mais l'impact
il est très indirecte c'est à dire que
c'est des profs qui vont être inspiré
pour faire des trucs avec les élèves etc
les élèves qu'on touche et il ya une
espèce d'impact invisible qui est
difficile à quantifier mais mais que je
commence à avoir faim j'ai fait une
intervention dans un collage hier
j'avais des profs qui me disaient qu'ils
regardent des vidéos science avec
beaucoup d'intérêt et que vous avez
resservait énormément quoi donc
donc c'est quelque chose qui je pense
qu'il faut promouvoir parce que à
promouvoir les sciences à l'école c'est
toujours une bonne chose surtout quand
c'est bien fait avec une une démarche
d'investigation mettre en avant la
méthode scientifique plutôt que les
faits tu dois apprendre ça par coeur et
voilà fait ça dans ton contrôler dans
deux semaines tu va l'oublier de
transformer des élèves en petits
chercheurs en herbe pour pouvoir les
faire penser comme des scientifiques je
pense que dans leur vie citoyenne plus
tard ça leur servira quoi ouais mais tu
que tu peux tu peux nous parler un peu
plus de cette confiance que tu as fait
rire car oui donc c'était la première
fois que je parlais à des collégiens
c'était un moment exceptionnel dans ma
vie je veux prendre quelques adresses
étaient dans le cadre d'un concours qui
s'appellera même ta science que
les données à à auxerre hier donc et
j'étais devant 150 collégiens de 6e à 3e
à qui j'ai raconté qu'ils sont les
descendants directs des étoiles et du
big bang et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'elle n'avait jamais fait devant un
public aussi jeune et j'avais beaucoup
d'appréhension parce que j'ai jamais
parlé à des collégiens avant et j'ai
cette idée est que le collège c'est un
monde horrible
les profs pour les élèves pour moi je ne
connais personne qui a apprécié ses
années de collège c'était un moment où
tu essaies de construire ton identité
c'est un moment où les gens sont cruels
envers toi et j'avais vraiment cette
idée du collège je traiterai touré tous
les élèves qui sont dissipés qui sont
qui sont pas attentifs qui sont sur leur
téléphone etc
et j'avais une heure alors consacré
d'ailleurs c'est long une heure c'est
long mais voilà je leur ai donné cette
conf et à chéu droit à une quasi
standing ovation avec des élèves y est
j'ai eu 150 collégiens qui sont venus me
voir à la fin pour signer des dédicaces
des salles et des questions les
questions plus ultra pertinentes comme
qu'est ce qui cause l'expansion de
l'univers à ce que les atomes sont vives
en face les trucs parfois j'étais
presque presque bloquée de leurs
questions parce que c'est des questions
ultra pertinentes et du jura
enfin on s'attend pas à est en question
des jeunes en fait et c'est ça que je
trouve génial c'est que généralement
quand on a des camps ont fait face à des
adolescents plus plus on fait face à des
gens qui sont vieux plus on a des
blocages psychologiques qui et sociaux
qui vont entrer en oeuvre et au bout
d'un moment souvent chez les adultes
c'est des gens qui n'osent pas poser de
questions alors soit soit ils vont pas
dans toutes les conférences de
vulgarisation avec dans lequel on peut
assister
on a toujours cette personne âgée qui
l'a levé la main pour pas pour poser une
question mais pour faire une renarde ça
c'était 100% des conférences qui sont
ceux qui sont comme ça donc on est des
gens qui sont de moins en moins curieux
au fil du temps parce que c'est
institutionnalisé et on n'a pas une
culture de l'erreur qui qui permet de
bien prendre le fait de se tromper ou de
ne poser une question qui peut ne pas
sembler pertinentes sur l'est sur le
moment même et plus on va vers d'aider
les enfants qui sont jeunes monde à ces
blocages là et alors ça commence à
s'institutionnaliser au collège et au
lycée
les gens nous posent de moins en moins
de questions notamment les filles parce
que c'est très très genre et comme comme
truc ouais on a tendance à pousser plus
les garçons à à se mettre en avant et
aux filles de se mettre en arrière et ça
commence à se voir
moi le moi je les ai vus pour le dire
donc c'est une chose qui est qui qui
mérite qui m'arrête plus attention quoi
leur est faite de de construire une
culture à l'école et dans la société ou
mots c'est pas grave de se tromper c'est
pas grave de poser des questions il n'y
a pas de questions dettes et je pense
qu'il ya énormément d'énergie qui est
gaspillé de la demande sur les chez les
profs chez les vulgarisateurs chez chez
les gens qui essaient de promouvoir
certains messages des blocages
psychologiques de des gens il ya plein
de choses à déconstruire quoi tu peux
poser des questions c'est pas grave si
tu penses de ne pas comprendre
il ya des questions qui sont qui ont
l'air en apparence super simple mais
mais qui sont ultra ultrahd complexe à
répondre je vous dis ranger l'une des
plus des conversations qui a changé ma
vie c'est quand j'ai parlé à mon petit
cousin de 7 ans à l'époque qui m'a
demandé mais ça ressemble à quoi un atom
par va répondre un truc de mécanique
quantique un gamin de sept ans j'ai
essayé mais j'ai vite vu mes limites à
ce niveau là et ça me fait vraiment me
remettre en question parce que jusqu'à
présent je vous dis je suis quand même
vachement bon en vulgarisation du donc
les restes retrouvés devant ce gamin de
7 ans qui pose une question qui te met
complètement en déroute et il ya
vraiment moyen d'apprendre d'apprendre
déjà nous casser des oeufs et ils
peuvent apprendre de nous mais nous on
peut aussi apprendre de cette notion
d'humilité et de falla de remettre les
choses un peu plus horizontale qu'elles
le sont à l'heure actuelle est pas de se
mettre sur son pied d'estale de savants
au dessus d'une masse grouillante et
ignorante je pense qu'il ya vraiment un
enjeu à la ce niveau là quoi de ouais
ouais
puisque tout passe des trucs qu'on sache
tout d'axa est d'accord avec
l'observation selon lesquelles parfois
c'est le truc qui sont beaucoup plus
faciles renseigner un enfant qui ont un
adulte pour adultes et tirons aussi j'ai
eu l'occasion de faire une conférence un
moment dans des collégiens que c'était
un truc matin jean montpellier où je
parlais de démocratie le système de vote
et la met vraiment eu l'impression que
aux moyens certaines certaine idée des
scrutins qui était plus facile à
expliquer à eux que des gens
- vous dire les matins ça va vainqueur
avec tout ça des symboles ça va mais des
gens pas tout à fait matheux qui ont
bloqué sur certains points ou qui vont
parler un peu hot et qu'on parle de
scrutin ils vont ils vont tout de suite
ramené au débat démocratie
représentative et en suisse est direct
et alors que je sais pas de ça dont je
parle que et voilà donc il ya quelque
chose à ce niveau-là et kassav a mené à
une pop hip hop vous pouvez me détester
j'ai dû envoyer vos messages de mort à
l'avancé ça j'avais déjà parlé avec avec
avec me tienne on vas tu veux dire ce
que j'en pense c'est que globalement
l'éducation en particulier en maths mais
peut-être pas mal dans d'autres
disciplines aussi mon parti qu en maths
l'enseignement à distance restante pour
l'interdire d'enseignement est en fait
globalement mené face pour la plupart
des gens à voir quasi totalité des gens
je sais pas si c'est une bonne
popularité note parce que je partage
aussi cet ouais je pense que l'éducation
en sciences et en maths des élèves les a
traumatisés les traumatismes de fléchir
en fait plusieurs plusieurs décennies
plusieurs centaines d'années que je
pense par le si on revient à l'histoire
de l'éducation en tout cas en france on
pas parler d'autres hauts des autos
début de l'école c'était on devait
former les petits soldats donc
les pouces et une certaine hiérarchie à
obéir à être dans les codes à papa
développer des idées complexes parce que
finalement on les considère pas comme
des humains on est prêt à livrer comme
des soldats en devenir et en a gardé
cette espèce de reste historique avec un
prof qui va qui va répandre son savoir à
des élèves
on commence à considérer les élèves
comme des êtres humains ça c'est déjà
une avancée par rapport à avant et on
commence même à les faire réfléchir par
eux-mêmes donc il ya encore une avancée
intéressante on n'a pas encore brisé le
système de hiérarchie c'est mon côté
anarchiste qui parle mais mais voilà on
commence à les considérer comme des yeux
mais il ya quand même ce reste deux il
ya un savoir légitime mais porté par des
savants vous allez apprendre ce serveur
parker est de toute façon si vous faites
des bonnes choses au concours à l'examen
ça va bien se passer ce sera valorisé
etc
sinon les autres trucs qui vont pas être
valorisés et on va valoriser d'autres
choses comme par des matières en
particulier comme les maths ou la
physique par rapport à d'autres comme
jallet l'histoire littérature ça sera
plus valorisées
ça va nous offrir plus de power tonneau
société et je pense que c'est la recette
parfaite pour créer des dénés trauma
quoi enfin je dirais la majorité des
gens avec qui je parle de physique et
c'est là là quand je généralement quand
on prononce le mot physique ou mat on
sent les gens qui se crispe mais c'était
très physique lancé très viscéral
parce que c'est des gens qui quand
l'ordi physique ou mat ce qu'ils pensent
c'est la physique et les maths que j'ai
appris quand j'étais en primaire et au
collège et au lycée et est parfois là la
différence entre ce qu'on apprend aux
lieux en l'ecal école est ce qu'on fait
en dans les labos de recherche
elle aimait gigantesque et a en fait
déconstruire on perd énormément de temps
le trouve à déconstruire ces images là
ce cette image du prof de physique un
peu un peu vieillot un peu
un peu vieille peau qui est généralement
très sévère voilà et qui a pu traumatisé
des élèves et c'est souvent le cas j'ai
l'impression que c'est plus la norme que
l'exception et ça me fait un peu peur
mais bara peut-être que c'est pas si
elle populaire de dire sa part une plaie
ce qu'est un peu plus on ne peut plus
rien c'est la conséquence de sa bon sens
et que d'enseigner les maths finalement
c'est pas bien quelque incident permet
d'arriver à cette conclusion j'ai juste
observations que globalement le
l'enseignement des maths me semble
globalement néfastes voire très néfaste
avec les gens c'est beaucoup plus dur
d'enseigner les maths à quelqu'un qui a
été traumatisée par aimar est moins que
quelqu'un qui qui ne sait même pas ce
que sont des maths ou mais c'est même
plus facile d'enseigner à quelqu un
quelque chose qui est des maths mais ne
le sait pas quelle est la cgtg n 2 bat
il ne savait pas que c'était impossible
alors ils l'ont fait et du coup c'est
sûr que si je fais le bilan de
l'enseignement des maths on lit les bras
je trouve vraiment catastrophique mais
en fait c'est les maths et qu'on y
enseigne aujourd'hui
après il ya un gap entre dire les
l'enseignement tel qu'on fait
aujourd'hui des maths amène à cette
conclusion qui est bas les gens sont
traumatisés et de dire l'enseignement il
faut pas d'enseignement des maths
il ya plein de manières d'enseigner des
matches qu'on n'a pas encore testé
aujourd'hui ouais mais il ya beaucoup de
pays dans le monde qui ont testé
différentes manières de faire des maths
et j'ai l'impression qu'une page
wikipédia sûr que c'était des matchs
sont pas anglophones
c'est à travers le monde et enfin c'est
vraiment un truc keller d'être assez
court et du coup de l'enseignement des
maths
à l'échelle globale avec différentes
tentatives différentes c'est parce que
c'est vraiment difficile de bien au
cellier matin ouais ça sur moi c'est pas
anodin mais mais je pense qu'il ya des
bonnes manières enfin on mate alors j'ai
peu j'ai peu de héros en maths mais y en
a un que j'aime que j'aime
particulièrement qui s'appelle edward
frenkel et loire frenkel c'est un
mathématicien russe je crois qui est un
orateur exceptionnel et qui en fait tu
parles de maths mais avec un angle qui
est l'angle de l'amour l'angle de
l'émotion alors on me demandait toujours
sur comment comment bien trop faire
passer un message et lui laisser un
passionné de maths dans un sens traître
quasi spirituelle en fait et le transmet
d'une manière que j'ai jamais vu enfin
ça c'est quelqu'un qui pendant une
conférence à y ait beaucoup d'histoires
personnelles la dent donc il y avait
beaucoup d'émotion et c'est quelqu'un
qui va généralement enfin si à l'aise
sur scène en interne farocki qui part de
matt quoi
parce qu'il ya une histoire vraiment
particulière à base de discrimination
est il écrit des supers bouquin sur sur
pourquoi les maths sont belles et
pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit considérer
les maths belle et ça veut dire quoi
beau et voilà est ce qu'ils étaient
juifs en russie ouais je prendrai des
squames qui est interdit il ya eu pas
mal d'antisémitisme
à cette époque là bas après je me pose
la question même si ben moi je sais pas
quand ils enseignent comment ça se passe
en classe mais par votre mac par exemple
beaucoup de gens pensent que je serai à
mon prof et je vais enseigner et je suis
assez catégorique je suis un très
mauvais profs les sur quels critères
je suis bon alors il faut que ces gens
seigneur pour de probabilités et
statistiques heures d'autres quoi aussi
mais en particulier m'a pas marqué
bordeaux notamment parce que voilà
c'était très statistiques classiques
aujourd'hui géorgie beaucoup de choses
qu'ils ont c'est surtout la manière dont
j'ai enseigné où on va essayé pas mal
aujourd'hui tu n'enseignerait de manière
plus biaisée qu'il ya cinq ans et
qu'elle refusera d'enseignés secours
ok j'ai enseignera trade parce que moi
j'étais bon en charge du programme du
court du coup j'étais j'avais un
programme à renseigner et un viol un
examen conan qui suce pas obligé
l'examen je suis obligé l'enseigné est
ce que je vais enseigner
du coup quand j'étais un petit peu mais
même j'avais pas du tout de recul
épistémologique ou pas de recul sur les
statistiques donc bon bah lots dont le
contenu est problématique
mais ses bars et ses limites
c'est pas à cause et compte tenu que je
pense avoir été très négatif en fait
dans cet enseignement c'est pour
respecter l'exigence du contenu du coup
mais voilà j'ai enseigné un peu les
statistiques comme les méthodes
utilisées et puis on rentrait dans plein
de détails techniques qui me semble
absolument pas pertinent enfin a retenu
ou va c'est si j'avais voulu retrouver
la loi devait bulls taper ça sur google
de l'apprendre savais même pas besoin
que vous le dise moi je sais pas et par
contre des trucs mais alors que je peux
vraiment importants comme les facteurs
de confusion le pardon de simpson ne
peux pas m que je sois vraiment
important était mentionné d'encours la
forme ne baisent un moment j'en ai parlé
quoi mais c'est tellement pas le truc
qui passent un examen c'est tellement
pas le truc prioritaire que je pense
qu'ils iraient vont pas retenu du tout
mais les stats c'est vachement dur parce
que c'est particulièrement difficile aux
seniors que moi je me rappelle de mes de
mes cours de step comme je l'avais en
deuxième année de master qui avec l'un
des plus grands pontes en stats appliqué
à l'astrophysique à l'heure actuelle est
en fait c'est ultra théorie qui on avait
on avait tous les théorèmes et on vous
avait filé un bouquin de 400 pages avec
tous les théorèmes et toutes les
statistiques fréquentes east mais j'ai
rien pigé quoi et en fait il a fallu
j'arrive en thèse en deuxième moitié de
ma thèse pourrait pour avoir abordé les
statistiques par moi même
en autodidacte et c'est là où j'ai
commencé à comprendre certains concepts
avant c'est une pro - c'était à part la
gothia n'y avait pas grand chose quoi
c'est ouais bah moi je l'enseigné je
considère que l'enseigné le cours de
statistiques sans comprendre
statistiques gens c'est ce qui avait
enseigné que moi et j'étais assez
mécanique et est alors c'était j'étais
pas non plus complètement débile quoi
mais j'étais quand même j'avais pu
manquer de 40 de recul et je pense que
les cours étaient chiant et c'était
ultra technique qui c'était ils
apprenaient pierrard julian pourquoi
revenir aussi sur l'esthétique sombre du
renseigné j'ai parlé la semaine dernière
avoir un ami mathématicien qui qui
enseigne à court de projets statistiques
cette deuxième année qui l'on sait pas
c'est la deuxième année qu'il enseigne
il des adieux pas mal changé son cours
par rapport à l'année précédente et je
pense qu'il va continuer à leur
permettre de changer les notations même
les terminologies c'est vraiment
vraiment difficile d'enseigner
statistique est bon bref on revenir à au
moins deux qui enseigne et statistiques
je pense que gorges était dégoûté des
statistiques et ils n'ont rien retenu de
partisans que c'est fin c'est vraiment
si l'on fait le bilan c'est je sais j'ai
effet souffert ils ont retenu une très
mauvaise expérience
elles vont tout jamais en faire de
statistiques et ils n'ont rien retenu
ouais carrément j'étais un mauvais profs
quand je veux dire toutes les cases s'en
suivent le rugby fait de le reconnaître
est là prêt de passer à une autre mais
c'est pas facile sinon c'est pas 62
c'est la première pierre ouais enfin je
t'ai pas mal de pierres la scène ce sont
des pierres mais tu as pleuré quand je
précise pour les enfants
personne ne parle de le jeter des
cailloux sur les devises dans les
cailloux les chutes de neige par cf la
vidéo de valentine delattre sciences de
comptoir pourquoi les géologues les jeux
des cailloux c'était une trêve et josh
mais maintenant vous en faites partie
je crois qu'il est déjà sorti quelques
par d'improbables basse etc mais va
cesser seront difficiles et nous avons
la statistique je pense que c'est
particulièrement difficile donc mitigé
cette excuse mais je pense que même les
matchs de façon assez générale c'est pas
facile en bien renseigné que j'ai fait
des vidéos en ligne dans le sens où je
vais enseigner du procès et de de maths
de nouveau terminal ou lycées et
s'échoue vrai c'est vraiment chiant le
problème c'est que je pense que tu peux
pas passer outre le fait d'apprendre
certains concepts mathématiques à des
gamins ou en tout cas d'aller à l'école
en tout cas parce que c'est des concepts
qui se retrouve partout dans notre
société
je veux dire que je pense pas bah quand
tu vois les résultats d'un sondage
quand tu le vois les algorithmes qui
sont utilisés pour te faire cliquer sur
des trucs que tu veux pas que sur
lesquels tu veux pas quitter de base
quand tu vois ce que ça fait juste pour
comprendre tête à l'aide d'un pot je ne
sais pas ça c'est des matchs dont tu as
besoin à ceillac hautes et très
pragmatique et à comprendre ces choses
chez soi on se bat pour ne pas se faire
avoir dans le monde il voyait en tout il
y en a un bagage statistiques et
mathématiques à avoir pour devenir un
citoyen fonctionnelle de cette société
alors justement des bottes j'ai déjà
parlé des battues avec mme maljean sur
quel est le bagage mathématiques
minimale et je pense que l'addition
c'est bien quand même
mais la division non vision comment
s'explique le concept d'équité ce qu'on
va voir et de vision enfin saisir une
question de à quel point tu rentres en
profondeur sur ce qu elle
division pu diviser une note par quatre
dont on voit ce que ça veut dire savoir
faire une division
c'est à dire poser une division ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas poser une
division mais à la dernière fois je les
fais ça ça m'a remonté leurs habitudes
savoir poser une multiplication je suis
presque prêt à dire que ouais c'est sûr
enfin importance je sais pas si c'est un
bagage minimum mais pas par moi je
m'arrêtais arrêté parce que bon mois
pour moi le truc qui est un peu la
limite vraiment entre est ce que c'est
un bagage fait partie du bagage minimum
ou pas
c'est la règle de trois bon oui je pense
que c'est pas mal c'est les gens les
connaissent en partie le truc le plus
utile qu'on nous apprend je pense ce
qu'en pratique personnelle comme fort
moi j'utilise tout en verre utilisé je
pense qu'elle peut même pas mal de gens
l'utilisent
mais enfin bon si ça peut être utile
mais je pense que beaucoup de gens qui
l'habitent rythme
oui peut-être mais pour comprendre les
règles de proportionnalité et c'est par
la proportionnalité
comme c'est un truc qui veulent la
proportionnelle et et je pense que c'est
un concept à voir ce serait borderline
bagage minimum je vais le pilote fait
non les gens passent ce bagage minimum 7
c'est difficile de dire ça comme ça hors
sol de dire de quoi est ce que la
société a besoin comme match car on a
besoin d'en savoir déjà qu'est ce que
c'est une bonne société être une
compétence en a besoin il faut faire une
liste exhaustive des ajouts les touts
les compétences dont on se s'étaient a
besoin pour fonctionner et pour
fonctionner bien on est les meilleurs
juges cela je ne sais pas quoi autant
aussi des statistiques que rejoindra
peut-être un peu jeu en particulier la
journée on parle de dieu c'est horrible
on remarque très important mais enfin
pas mal voilà peut-être moyenne médiane
variant ses médecins volta et puis après
je m'apprête à la fin la loi je pense
que c'est bien c'est un peu trop
technique après il n'y a pas si on
regarde le contenu du programme scolaire
collèges et lycées
ouais il ya plein de choses je suis si
on me demande ça les jeux parce que
c'est ben edelman house est puni maurice
teguel fait une blague
est ce que vous êtes et utilise un
compas
notre vie car mon nom enfin je veux dire
moi je suis un maître compost
mathématicien que c'est mon papa rech
je perde pas dans quel contexte y aura
bien un coupable à ses débuts par contre
enfin au delà de l'enseignement des
statistiques où je trouve qu'il ya
tellement de manière de manipuler des
statistiques pour des sébastien en train
de compter jusqu'à trois tellement de
manières d'utiliser les statistiques
venant des fins idéologiques pour
manipuler des gens que c'est fondamental
pour moi de donner quand tout cas ses
clés la aux gens d'aujourd'hui
quand vous avez un graff sur bfm tv avec
avec un diagramme camembert ou vous avez
les trois quarts du guardian camembert
qui est qui est rempli pour vous dire
qu'un truc rempli à 30% faut le voir ce
genre de choses là on voit qu'on essaie
de manipuler là on voit que quelque
chose qui va pas et ayant fait c'est on
a besoin de ça pour une société
fonctionnel on a besoin de gens qui
réfléchissent un peu plus que parent qui
gobent bas tout ce qu'on leur présente
ouais alors ça nique jeux suivants vélo
des vieux bien l'admettre dans le bagage
minimum mais c'est réfléchir un petit
peu comment est-ce qu'on réfléchisse et
tout ça me fait mais je suis pas sûr que
ce soit en cours de match il faut non
seulement ce n est pas ça ne sais pas
ils m'aiment pas mal des concepts qu'on
n'utilise je trouve ça chiant l'entrée
dans l'enseignement cours de maths parce
que bon on fait ou fait la technique on
apprend la technique en matière d'accès
du match n'était que de la technique
donc que si l'enseigné savais pas qu'il
y avaient recours d'esprit critique oui
je pense quoi oui si tu apprenais ce qui
était une dérive est en cours de
physique jamais en maths
là les gens se diraient pas à
s'acclimater sahara
parce que
oui en effet elle aurait pas de cours de
maths donc ils pompent à sa plainte que
ça sert à skis connaissons même pas
travailleur peut-être une amélioration
possible de l'enseignement des maths
c'est de partir d'un cas très concrets
avant de partir sur d'autres les choses
abstraites
alors je crois que c'est quelque chose
de très très français ça de d'enseigner
les maths de manière très abstraite avec
ça tu as lu sait pas quand andy que non
c'est pour de kittur daiichi
il ya un petit peu révolutionné la
manière d'enseigner les maths
aujourd'hui et et on est clairement sur
de l'enseignement hors sol des
mathématiques du coup c'est fort c'est
forcément que les gens vont me dire que
les maths ça sert à rien dans la dans la
vie de tous les jours parce qu'on leur a
jamais fait le lien entre leur vie de
tous les jours et les maths
donc je pense qu'à partir de ça des cas
très concret de la vie de mettre des
liens entre les maths et les gens ça
peut aider papa peut-être un réseau tous
les problèmes mais ça peut aider c'est
un débat aussi que j'ai récemment sur à
quel point est ce que ma part tant que
je pense qu'on a vu carnation de
mathématiques ça c'est globalement une
erreur de bouira de concret ce regard
des vidéos de mickael son nom l'indiqué
le plus grand et puis fit cul oui à
prendre un des îles va le lancer et puis
le ta-100 vins fins et puis valéo tiens
c'est marrant des trucs qui servent à
rien comme c'est les maths absolument
pas concrète mais c'est même mieux fins
et il ya toujours cette envie de se
raccrocher à quelque chose de concret du
coup tu es obligé le truc d'expliquer le
truc concret sur rien - dans un rapport
de statistique j'avais enseigné ce qu'on
appelle les aiguilles de buffon les
pires méthodes pour quelques lépi et du
coup je suis assez trop court pas faire
ça avoir piqué la paix va le savoir est
quelqu'un de valeur hors droits de pi
tout ça est en fait c'est juste plus de
choses a expliqué bon après le court
était très nouvelle global mais oui j'ai
l'impression que cet exemple est aidée
que
être concret ce c'est un coup comme just
you tube a été vidé o weh concrètes dans
très peu de concret on allait les
métaphores sont concrètes si tu veux
quand on fait de la vulgarisation on a
des métaphores qui peuvent nous aider
dans l'explication
si je disais juste que là la gravité la
gravité telle que vus dans la relativité
générale cour de l'espace temps du fait
que au centre des étoiles biais de la
fusion nucléaire qui se créent chaque
race
non en fait c'est pas du tout concret
mais la manière contrainte de le dire
c'est que quand vous compris d'un gaz
qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous faites
quand vous compris benghazi comme quand
vous avez votre pompe à vélo et quand
vous avez votre pompe à vélo parce que
si vous touchez votre pompe à vélo c'est
ça chauffe
ouais donc un gaz comprimé ça chauffe
donc ça c'est quelque chose que tout le
monde peut expérimenter si ils ont assez
d'argent pour se payer un vélo et une
pompe à vélo
ouais mais c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut se représenter et qui va être
retenue après on va pas retenir le côté
relativité générale physique dégâts
thermodynamique etc mais on va retenir
l'analogie du de la pompe à vélo j'ai
l'impression que les raisons pour
lesquelles les gens adorent tes vidéos
chars des roquettes gmt vidéo dans
laquelle j'adore tes vidéos 24
c'est absolument pas pour des raisons
concrètes même l'opposé comme cessé d'en
sortir du contrat que ouais alors moi
voilà la raison pour laquelle je fais
ces vidéos la raison principale en
l'avenir c'est de sortir les gens de
leur quotidien
c'est à dire votre vie elle ne se limite
pas à prendre le métro tous les jours
pour aller bosser etc
il ya des choses dans l'univers
qui sont absolument épique il ya des
choses dans l'univers qui sont qui sont
des lois il ya une valeur esthétique et
une valeur politique
mais ces choses elles sont aussi liées à
vous d'une manière qu'on voit pas
forcément là dedans mais ces choses-là
sont liées à vous et le but de la
science c'est de révéler ses liens
cachés
les notices et que nous monteith et
c'est important de le dire ça que quand
on est liés à l'univers ça se passe
ces plaques bon pour moi j'ai déjà vrai
est un de mes grands combats dans la vie
alors on va se faire un resto c2c de
découvrir cette idée selon laquelle on
fait pas partie de la nature et on est
au dessus de la nature ça c'est une idée
qui nous vient d'aristote
ça a été institutionnalisée par le
christianisme voilà on est au dessus des
animaux on est au dessus de tours parce
que au final on est la créature audi
donc pourquoi pas et ça je pense que
c'est à la base de pas mal de pas mal de
catastrophe dans l'histoire de
l'humanité en fait je trouve que c'est
une idée qui est vraiment toxique et qui
mériterait d'être remises remis dans un
dans un contexte plus plus plus fiable
plus vrai et c'est ce contexte c'est le
complexe de la science qui nous qui nous
dit que à plein des chaînes différentes
on peut se voir avec plein de lune est
différente et on se voit à chaque fois
différemment mais on n'est pas ce truc
monolithique convoi dans le métro tous
les jeux pourquoi le nom si pas ça mais
quand même il ya no way tu t'es de
rainvillers l'agenda politique et secret
des scènes secondaires secret mais mais
je trouve sympa façon nécessaire de
ramener ces nous voir le meilleur
compliment que j'ai eus bonne foi j'ai
calé à passer à la radio tout s'appelle
et versus pensait sur rts radio c'est
miss paris de l'infini dans une semaine
où les jouets des philosophes ou je sais
pas trop
d'autres gens qui parlent de l'infini
mais souvent de façon assez tue pas
concrète on dirait que c'est fini c'est
ça de façon assez fini et du coup il
voulait avoir figuré ce nom il parlait
du fini en fait il paraît défini pendant
toute la semaine
pas mal de changements climatiques et
mon genre à la vergne et tout ça donc
des trucs assez concret et tout ça et
puis j'ai voulu finir la semaine sur les
maths
ils m'ont invité à parler de l'infini et
du coup pareil que ce truc absolument
pas concret je parie que je suis paré de
la giz j'ai parlé de contrat tout
s'arrêterait pas avec lui j'adore et à
la fin la présentatrice donc en off dit
j'ai eu vous indiquer lequel elle est
aimée et elle a dit j'ai l'impression
d'avoir fut un jour c'est le mien alors
je sais pas je ne sais pas qui est son
fournisseur mais mais mais je pense
qu'il ya 25 ans et je ne partais pas la
passion du mathématicien c'est pas le
truc concret ah oui non mais ça je suis
partagé par mes demandes accord et
d'ailleurs je veux un contre-exemple à
tout ce que je viens de dire en maths la
lune
l'une des choses qui m'a le plus touchée
en mathématiques de toute ma vie en fait
c'est pas tout mais pas toutes mes mates
de prépa apatou playmate de master pas
tout mais maître de thèse
sa formule c'était un documentaire qui a
été fait par etienne j ce qui s'appelle
qui s'appelle dimension du maintien
donc si vous tapez dimension on
tomberait sur une super chaîne en
astrophysique mais vous trouverez aussi
sur un documentaire des tennis
donc il a fait une suite qui s'appelle
chaos et l'idée c'est d'avoir une espèce
de documentaires en vision en images de
synthèse qui vous fait un voyage dans la
quatrième dimension et en fait ça c'est
que j'ai jamais vu les matches comme ça
avant avant de voir ce documentaire
alors il faut savoir qu'il m'a filé
littéralement mal à la tête c'est la
première fois que voyaient un film qui
m'a coûté une migraine mais j'étais
satisfait de cette migraine quoi parce
que c'était j'avais littéralement mind
longue et j'ai trouvé ça absolument
génial enfin voila c'est honteux faisait
voyager dans un monde abstrait qui a un
espèce de paysages et que tu peux pas
voir directement le fait voyager quand
même y aller cette question
d'exploration d'un monde nouveau que qui
moi m'a touché énormément et ça je
trouve que c'est une belle manière
d'expliquer les maps par exemple sûrs et
cette notion de voyage
il est le fractal aussi c'est un truc
c'est un truc génial on te fait une
plongée des vidéos de plonger dans des
fractales sur youtube il y en ad chier
et à chaque fois là t'as pas
l'impression d'avoir pris un joint pas
l'impression d'avoir pris du tout les
couleurs et c'est vrai que c'est trop
trop n'émergeait patrie de l'az et donc
j'imagine que ça ressemble à ça ouais 40
et être payé toute cette dimension qui
est d'ailleurs si les gens veulent
vraiment aimer les maths c'est pas avec
le concret mon premier lieu il ya pas de
quelque part d'un moment il faut il faut
planer comme il faut on va y aller je
pense que les deux approches sont
complémentaires en fait c'est juste
qu'il faut pas les faux pas à les
séparer complètement parce que chaque
personne est différente dans sa manière
de recevoir ce genre de message est
autant une approche va toucher quelqu'un
est pas touché une autre tu peux en
étant complémentaires je suis maximise
la possibilité de toucher le maximum de
personnes si tu veux ouais il est urgent
d' équilibre tu vas essayer des
mathématiciens qui veut le faire de
vulgarisation très probablement très
rapidement on va leur conseiller d'être
concret d'être un exemple concret
nadia par un pic à skis oui d'accord
avec moi sur ce pont ces normes ont
essayé de partager de la passion quoi le
truc qui vous fait vibrer on a la
passion c'est une chose de concret
wawatie lui appelé seo concret oui ces
noms légendaires ça c'est très humain la
passion on veut dire c'est communicatif
la passion moi je veux dire pas un
exemple d'application concrète des
mathématiques ouais mais moi je te parle
pas juste de jeu par peu juste du
contenu mais le contenant est aussi
important que le contenu des genres dans
ce genre d'enseignement
je veux dire yahia julien bobroff qui
est un physicien qui est absolument
géniale qui fait beaucoup de
vulgarisation en physique quantique donc
un truc qui est très abstrait et il
raconté dans une interview comme quand
il donnait des conférences à des lycéens
ou à des jeunes
lisa il retenait jamais rien de ce que
de ce que c'était à la physique
quantique etc
par contre il repartait avec une image
de la science de la physique et qui
était beaucoup meilleur que ce qu'ils
avaient au départ parce que julien
bobroff savait transmettre sa passion à
travers son rang son langage corporel à
travers sa voix à travers le les
expressions qu'il utilise est sage je
trouve que c'est pas un truc à négliger
quand on fait de l'enseignement de aussi
réfléchir à la forme de ce parti c'est
le même problème même problématique en
vulgarisation mais en enseignement aussi
je pense que l'on gagnerait à apprendre
des compteurs on gagnerait à prendre les
artistes de rue
comment capter l'attention comment faire
en sorte que ton message soit reçu de la
manière la plus efficace possible
après biya via l'éducation c'est
compliqué parce que la wii non
clairement faut vraiment manquer des
analystes énormément de gens en faut et
puis il ya le format quand toi aussi je
pense que je viens tu étais un peu
mégalo je pense que je raconte assez
bien l'histoire qui me plaisent mais
me mets devant une classe 2
quelques ont enseigné encore de
statistiques c'est dur c'est pas moi je
pense qu'il ya une vraie difficulté de
la part des profs parce qu'en fait ils
sont dans une situation où leur public
et captifs ils sont littéralement
emprisonnés ils peuvent pas sortir de la
salle sans aggraver que ayez aussi il ya
un programme mais je veux dire à partir
du moment où on a un public captif où il
peut pas sortir
on a un peu comparé avec un a priori
négatif de la part du public
est-ce que c'est des gens qui viennent
pas là pour par curiosité personnelle il
donne pas la passe que par ce qu'ils
veulent mais ils viennent parce qu'ils
sont obligés et est en fait le travail
du prof qui est absolument difficile et
je pense que je serai un très mauvais
profs fois ci si j'étais prof c'est de
non seulement 2,2 de déconstruire cette
image que les autres que le public a de
base de la matière et ensuite de
reconstruire a une qui soit désirable et
à et pour les profs qui arrive à faire
ça alors moi j'en connais pas beaucoup
j'en ai connu deux dans toute ma
scolarité de prof de physique absolument
géniaux mais mais c'est rare ces gens là
un proche de m il vit bourthes et
bizarrement un programme atv-2 y aura
très bientôt avait produit un point
mais c'est facile et du coup un vin
tapas typiquement là dans l'oeil
préscolaire de 15 du lycée il ya l'image
qu'ils sont plus obligatoires du monde
mais aussi avoir fait de deux matchs
pour le premier un terminal intéressant
je connais pas trop dans les détails
tout et pas mal de gens qui sont plaints
de 10 ans mais il veut sortir il ne pas
savoir ce que ses bas blancs moelleux du
christ a été le cas pour la svt aussi et
là ça m'a plu ça m'a vraiment voilà là
j'étais vraiment révolté quoi parce que
si la svt devient
il ya des idées tellement fondamentale
en résultait que soit l'évolution que ce
soit comment fonctionne une planète bon
débat le basque 20 pour les maths moi
j'étais content enfin beaucoup trop de
battre son plein temps et matt cain
partout et tout ça mais je fais encore
ce conseil que le grand enseignement des
maths est plus néfaste que bénéfique et
je pourrais faire le même fin je les
défends la vannetaise en fait pour pas
mal de matière
est-ce que ce que vont les factions à
cet argument massue on n'explique pas
aux gens pendant fonctionner vaccins ils
seront pas mais on pratique beaucoup de
gens m'ont appris à l'école ce qui est
dans un accent pourquoi ça fonctionnait
et on a quand même pas mal de gens qui
parce que l'on retient pas grand chose
finalement
donc est ce que c'est vraiment
nécessaire de l'enseigné je sais parce
que ça peut se discuter samedi ses deux
fils de voir l'impact culturel que ça
peut avoir de paf ne pas enseigner
quelque chose ou de l'enseigné je veux
dire par là les études sur de comparer
plusieurs pays en matière d'éducation
sur les tests pisa et ses terrasses et
c'est vachement difficile et parfois je
sais pas quel crédit il faut apporter à
ces trucs là parce que il ya tellement
de facteurs culturels et donc valoir
différents qu'on met sur différentes
choses que comparer c'est ce genre de la
proche je veux pas être le statisticien
qui fait ça tu vois puis facteur tout
partout ça il ya tellement de facteurs
impliqués c'est invivable quoi ouais
mais il ya des signaux qui sont assez
fort et quand un des signaux qui assez
fort et c'est par exemple le dégoût du
vrai thématiques
ouais alors je suis d'accord sur le
constat sur la solution de ces femmes
refuserait à avoir un avis tranché avant
d'en savoir plus quoi mais en savoir
plus n'avait trait d'avoir plus de
moyens pour ça m'avait fait de sacrifier
une génération pour avec pas deux pas du
tout de maths en obligatoire à l'école
et on verra ce que ça donne ce que s'il
ne suit pas très bas ici tout ça alors
oui alors je leur dirai c'est un
bayésiens parfait il faut le savoir je
vais le dire publiquement comme ça c'est
fait je suis par balise un parfait parce
que enfin disons que j'ai une espèce de
d'intuition bayésienne maintenant tu
commences ta développer c'est pas facile
à développer
c'est très dur notamment il ya des
petits algorithmes que bahia dire que tu
que tu peux internaliser en mode tenir
compte de tes propres à priori avant de
formuler un jugement ça s'est passé pas
quelque chose de mathématiques ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut qu'on peut
faire dans la vie de tous les jours on
calculait un calcul et une likelihood
dans la vie de tous les jours on va pas
faire ça berne estime être être dans une
approche où on est prêt à remettre son
jugement en question à la lumière de
nouvelles données je trouve que c'est
une approche saint seine et je serai
prêt à le promouvoir publiquement après
après je ne suis pas un baliser un
parfait jeudi ont fait pas ça tous les
jours non plus enfin bouclé rebond n'est
pas je ne suis pas une créature
complètement rationnelle et tous les
choix que je fais dans la vie de tous
les jours ne sont pas du tout et c'est
pas grave mais ce que tu voudrais être
bayésiens bertin louise je sais pas si
j'étais complètement va et vient je
serai un robot en fait et je ne sais pas
si c'est désirable parce qu'en fait si
j'étais un robot il y aurait le coût
social de jeu serait vue comme la
personne la personne rationnelle et la
personne qui prend toutes ses décisions
de manière rationnelle et le fait de
devenir le data ou le monsieur spock de
pont d'univers
c'est un coût social classes sociales je
pense que tu fais lénine vidéo de jus
lagaf qui s'appelle de wolken semaines
l'homme de paille à vulcain âge
gfr c'est un petit peu ça l'idée c'est
imaginer que la être rationnel c'est
c'est être monsieur spock sspa qui est
vachement pas proche mais pas très bien
star trek donc à monsieur spock y voit
c'est la personne qui montre jamais
d'émotion qui pente qui prend toujours
des décisions qui semblent contre
intuitive mais qui sont réfléchies et en
fait enfin c'est souvent ça oscille sans
arguments de jag âge c'est que non mais
j'ai ce pack est vraiment pas rationnel
oui alors en pratique ne l'est pas mais
je viens c'est de l'image qu'on en a
c'est qu'il est bonne même l'image qu'on
en donne est vraiment passionné de vin
que vous
on peut prendre sheldon cooper théorie
comme moi ouais il faut avoir des
références dans la vie probablement un
podcast consommés par des guides ce
qu'il ya quelques geeks qui les aigus tu
mets donc si je prends chez john cooper
il ya plein de choses qui font tiquer un
manque de compréhension de textes
sociaux dû se retirer car après c'est la
limite de la des références culturelles
pour pour expliquer un phénomène est ce
que je voulais dire c'est que on est on
est pas une
on n'est pas à notre notre hardware il
c'est pas juste un cerveau dans une cuve
ou quoi c'est aussi des émotions c'est
aussi et en fait ça nous il ya un
podcast de m caca dessus d'ailleurs la
nuit ils interviewent antonio damasio
qui est
un spécialiste des émotions et qui
raconte que nos émotions jouent un grand
rôle dans de prise de décisions et en
fait de se considérer comme juste un
cerveau qui prend des décisions
rationnelles compense rationnelle c'est
une mauvaise approche et c'est une
approche qui peut être délétère quand on
essaie de dar d'études par déjà
d'étudier comment fonctionne le
comportement humain mais je trouve que
voir va reprendre décision dans un
contexte social émotif c'est aux fins
c'est aussi une forme de rationalité et
enfin en fait voilà peut-être que il
faut il faut définir ce que c'est la
rationalité peut-être il ya la
définition vraiment sociologique et la
définition psychologique et la
définition y viennent je pense que tant
qu'on sera pas d'accord sur qu'est-ce
que c'est la rationalité ou pas c'est là
c'est l'axé là où il faut débat sur les
mots je pense du coup tu le 30 coco va
prendre à une bonne définition de
rationalité c'est d'atteindre des buts
de la manière la plus efficace possible
qu'elle soit que ce soit dans une prise
de décision où tu vas limiter le nombre
de fois où tu vas faire des erreurs avec
un algorithme mental ou
wallah d'atteindre des quêtes
principales et secondaires avec le
maximum de succès ou si je t'ai dit
maximiser l'expérience de l'utilité ça
donne huawei goethe en soit c'est une
bonne manière me voir mais après calcul
et l'utilité je pense qu'il ya une
limite dans la dans la proche de calcul
et l'utilité parce que là on vit dans un
monde tellement complexe que calculer la
fonction de l'utilité c'est pas parce
est accomplie table quoi c on est obligé
d'avoir un soin d des fonctions
approcher et en fait à partir du moment
où on formalise ça on se rend compte des
limites de notre formalisation et on
prend le risque d'être pas de se limiter
dans une certaine vision de la
rationalité tu vois et g après j'ai pas
énormément réfléchi là dessus un jeu car
il parle comme si comme si j'étais un
invité de basket mais non pas du tout
presque un état qui a fait l'analogie
mais voilà quoi tu sais ce que je veux
dire c'est que prendre d'un thé quand on
interagit dans un contexte où les
décisions rationnelles sont pas
forcément les décisions les plus
valorisé socialement la décision en bêta
rationnelle ce serait le prendre ce
contexte là en question j'ai pas dit ça
si sa dîme était rationnel fin m'a fait
ça serait vraiment le truc vraiment
rationnelles well as le temps est
maussade au rationnel
ouais ouais je
les ouailles mais je pense que ça
titille arrive jamais vraiment quoi le
la rationalité complète dans un monde
idéal tout le monde est rationnel et
tout le monde maximy sa fonction
d'utilité
une fonction qui existe qui a dix mille
variable lee milliards de variables des
10 puissance 20 variable mais en
pratique on vit pas dans ce monde donc
n'en a pas de souci on revient un peu la
relation entre les émotions et oui on va
dire la décision de direction générale
donc je suis en train de de d'écouter un
livre de d david byrne je me trompe
diamond phillips s'appelle feeling good
way je passe souvent il paraît que c'est
un livre qui a cassé pas modifié dans
dans le mouvement est très efficace
donc c'est un livre en cailly puisque du
coup d'oeil burns et je veux dire de
bêtises donc je vous coupe donc le livre
parle de méthodes pour essayer de se
sentir mieux notamment à destination de
personnes
en dépression mais aussi n'importe qui
un peu énervé comment se calmer lorsque
m'énerver comment comment mieux débattre
surtout pour cet aspect que j'ai lu le
livre à la base mais en fait et à part
on m'a dit aussi je lui faudra que j'y
aurai fini avec eux il y ait des études
sinon que les gens qui lit ce livre se
soigne beaucoup mieux que ce qu'ils vont
voir des psychiatres classique
c'est un bon argument de vente c'est à
quel point c'est vrai moi tous les
services que je rencontrais vivant qui
le rend très intéressant est vraiment le
l'idée de ce livre c'est que l'on peut
contrôler ses émotions que l'on peut on
peut prendre du recul sur nos émotions
et en particulier voyez les émotions de
son très désirable si je suis passionné
par une meute
j'ai fort et que ça fait plaisir va je
veux continuer à développer même cette
passion voire même l'augmenter et c'est
un truc que je fais assez activement en
dix ans dans une vidéo de milk and honey
je suis un peu fatigué mais je vais
quand même elle va avoir comme ça ça va
motiver la faire des maths mais à
l'inversé des émotions qui sont ici on
négative est pratiquement être être
énervé envers quelque chose la colère
peut être productive
donc c'est pas juste être énervé qui
émane mais c'est dans certains contextes
elle être énervé et c'est
contre-productif on dit n'importe quoi
si la suite est du coup ce qu'on veut ce
que ce que dit david byrne c'est que il
ya il faut faire attention à ça et ils
se posent les questions de progression
et harvey et désiré ce qu' il ya de
bonnes raisons de la dragonnière avec un
script 9 s'était pas fait exception
moderne le stoïcisme en fait alors je
pense qu'il soit ici indique le seuil
fixé du bonheur que l'on appelle la
police qui l'a dit c'est que tu il ya
des choses que tu peux contrôler leur
poids et des choses que tu peux pas
contrôler genre l'extérieur et tu peux
pas contrôler l extérieur du coup du
coup en fait toutes les émotions qui te
traverse statut par contre tu peux tu
peux contrôler ton univers intérieur
pour être le bleu plus le plus proche de
la terre actifs
des tas de bonheur rationnelle qui chez
les grecs
je pense que c'est assez proche en effet
mais il ya eu cette discussion c'est
d'identifier les colères enfin découvrir
les toutes les passions et non pas aux
émotions qui sont on a envie de vouloir
d'avoir et celle qu'on n'a pas envie
d'avoir à y réfléchir à ça et ça fait
partie d'une certaine manière de la
rationalité
ouais mais peut-être après je peins pour
peut-être pour nuancer de parler
peut-être là la manière dont plus
présenter et peut-être limité par
rapport à ce que le bouquin dit mais je
vois une dérive à ce genre de
raisonnement ou de dire on a on a le
contrôle sur nos propres émotions
il ya une dérive qui souvent dans les
milieux de développement berd dans le
milieu de développement personnel qui va
dire vas tu es là tu es le seul
responsable de tes émotions et en fait
ça c'est peut être ça peut être des
discours qui au contraire peuvent
culpabiliser beaucoup de gens qui font
déjà des efforts mais qui mais qui sont
pas les bons efforts responded bouquins
et ça peut avoir cet effet
contre-productif de mettre les gens à
dos ou désespéré encore plus alors
qu'ils sont dans cette situation qui est
à la base pas du tout simple quoi on
parle énormément de tout ça bon
forcément est un peu l'idée du bouquin
donc par rapport à 20 euros cessé d'être
d'accepter de faire des erreurs de même
célébrer les erreurs ouais ça mais ça je
crois on comprend mais beaucoup mieux
beaucoup toi et moi mais aux éclats car
en essaient de profiter des erreurs et
puis aussi je pense que cette notion de
faute de responsabilité de
deux coupables culpabilité sont des
messages qui sont souvent faites très
contre-productif
ouais je pense aussi et par ace et des
sentiments si on pense que se sentir
responsable nous fait pour dire non plus
malheureux en plus nous rendre moins
efficace parce que tu peux tu peux quand
même vouloir la pression le stress
bénéfique tu vois réfléchira est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui vraiment une
émotion que je voudrais avoir est
typiquement une des émotions qu'on fait
et son entreprise il c'est de se sentir
responsable coupable
sa partenaire dans une vision un peu en
temps castro finistère j'ai une vision
un peu déterministe dumont quoi un peu
et bien manger à chaque fois que je fais
quelque chose et que je pense à peut
regretter les choix ouais enfin ça
arrive heureusement d'ailleurs
mais pour limiter le coût émotionnel de
ça je me dis que si tu les fais c'est à
cause des conditions initiales de
lignières c'est la faute à l'univers que
c'était plein d'univers de carrasco mais
techniquement pourquoi pas je veux dire
les lois de la physique de la biologie
de la chimie des sociétés impose des
contraintes qui limitent mes choix dans
la vie de tous les jours et il faut
apprendre à vivre avec quoi je veux dire
notre libre arbitre est limitée par
essence s'ils existent mais bref voilà
faut encore définir les barbes et il
faut après il ya quand même
[Musique]
il est comme cette tension entre enfin
si tu veux agir sur le monde doit
prendre ce que je voudrais agir si j'ai
eu ces univers et déterministe et bien
sûr mais tu peux te dire que tu agis sur
le monde parce que l'univers est venu à
curgies sur le mont dossier s'appuie à
certaines idées qu'il apparaisse que
dans certains contextes politiques et
culturelles donné quoi j'allais rendre
généralement les larges effet déjà pris
des cours en histoire dans les dans les
moments de l'histoire où on a des
tensions sociales importantes
c'est là où les nouvelles idées émergent
des idées comme le terrorisme
le confucianisme etc elles n'ont pu
émerger que parce que la classe
politique et ait été pourri parce que
les y avait des tensions entre
différentes factions de la société et
voilà donc et c'est dans ces contextes
là que ces idées peuvent émerger
le taoïsme confucianisme toutes les
philosophies qu'on a à l'heure actuelle
elle aurait j'allais nrg si on avait pas
ces contextes là et pourtant ça a été on
a tendance à mettre en avant les gens
qui les ont promu parce que bas il ya un
biais du scion viroquois berne et
souvent cdi des idées qui sont dans
l'air du temps on va dire l'évolution
darwin était pas seul à bosser sur
l'évolution voilà si la marque donc le
fait que les espèces évoluent au fil du
temps c'était une idée qui était dans
l'air du temps et le contexte a fait que
ces idées donc pu émerger et évidemment
aujourd'hui on célèbre darwin et on a
raison de le faire parce qu'il a fait un
travail incroyable mais mais s'il n'y
avait pas le ci avait pas darwin les
parents mme darwin
genfit fitzroy qui a engagé darwin dans
son bateau les constructeurs du bateau
les océans la vie sur terre
il y aurait pas eu darwin et tous les
gens qui ont qui ont nourri nouri darwin
passe de darwin c'était aussi un fils de
bourgeois donc donc la tôle et où les
petites gens qui font car on sait que
certaines personnes être mises en avant
il faut aussi le prendre en compte est
donc à la lie à la lumière de ce genre
de philosophie du groupe a de cette
vision la revoir le libre arbitre c je
trouve que c'est important que pour dire
pas si on si on enferme cette personne
en prison c'est peut-être pas parce que
il y avait ils avaient le choix de faire
ce qu'il avait fait quoi ces traits de
gauche de dire ça mais finalement le
village de gauche droite c'est ce moment
ça tient beaucoup à la la responsabilité
interne et externe donc ouais j'ai une
vidéo ou voir le vidéo je parle de
justice en libre arbitre ouais enfin
juste ans en deux mots bongo l'idée
c'est que avoir des des lois ça certains
définition ça sert pas en fait à la
punir quelqu'un ça sert à empêcher les
gens ont donné lundi leur accord aux
gens de pacoima trois mois la nation des
exemples quoi comme ça pendant force la
norme dans la seconde les inciter quoi
ouais et puis voilà c'est sûr depuis
enfin juste donné incentive en paix ma
vie comme des marionnettes
on suit un peu les ce qu'on a intérêt à
faire et
[Musique]
je pense qu'elle n'est pas la seule
raison sap est quelqu'un fait que tu
aller en prison
ouais pas envie de tuer quelqu'un voyez
d'autres raisons pour ne pas vouloir
tuer quelqu'un c'est pas cool mais parce
que du coup il ya un peu cette parce qu
enfin moi moi moi je vous crois pas au
libre arbitre tout ça mais j'aime quand
même penser que ça fait plaisir de
penser que j'ai quand même eu berthet
actions en tout cas que le processus de
prise de décision est quelque chose d
intéressant parce que c'est vachement
vite il d'avoir sa sensation en empêche
c'est vachement utile en pratique pour
le terme et dément la sueur de leur
front l'illusion deuxième arbitre cette
ville et beaucoup de chercheurs qui
pensent que ça a évolué non seulement
parce que ça donne un avantage évolutif
mais la conscience donne un avantage
évolutif pas négligeable sur la survie
de l'espèce
donc c'était un peu bêta mais deux ou
quatre ans quand david barnes il faut
qu'il faut gérer ses émotions et choisir
celle qui nous font bien en gros vous
bien bien prendre mes décisions ça fait
partie tout cas à réfléchir à comment je
prends la décision et fait partie de
notre truc que j'ai envie d'avoir en
main les choses comme ça il n'en est
intéressante et puis on nettoie aussi
dont il parle beaucoup c'est qu'un truc
moi qui ai assez vieillot bail à nice on
va dire c'est fait que ce qui est
intéressant c'est le processus de prise
de décisions et pas lui
enfin les faits en tant que tel qui sera
observé sont donc qui sont d'une
connaissance limitée façon du monde mais
par contre le processus des sciences ça
c'est un truc
qui fait quoi je pense que quelqu'un de
rationnel serait quelqu'un qui réfléchit
à la prise de décision qui essaie de
prendre une décision qui avec les
données qu'il a et la puissance de
quelques kilos va vers maximiser quelque
chose qu'il souhaite en plus maximiser
ouais ouais ouais ouais je sais pas
c'est à définir ces trucs là place à
définir décernés dans l'idée jeux dans
l'idée je vois mais en pratique je vois
pas tu vois c'est ça qui limite mon
instinct bayésiens en pratique il ya pas
mal de passes que du coup si tu fais ça
du coup il ya toujours la question de
mon processus de décision et elle qu' il
ya un livre tant que je recompte je
contrôle il s'appelle féminine betts
annie duke et jesse de poker donc penser
en termes de paris donc s'il vous au
poker ça se comprend et puis c'est très
balisé en fait concerner le pari c'est
un peu le truc de base du mondialisme et
est ce que ça dit c'est que quand on
fait un processus de décision comme ça
on est étonné que l'on a et puis après
idéalement vous appliquez la forme de
baisses pour essayer d'imaginer les
conséquences des différentes actions qui
commanderont
mais du coup c'est indispensable de
mettre des probabilités de dire si je
fais ça pour moi qui savais que ça va
conduire à sa voix sa propriété entière
ça va faire notre truc
puis si je fais cet autre chose bon bah
ça change les progrès et du coup pour
pouvoir faire ce processus de décision
il est indispensable d'avoir mis quelque
part des probabilités
ouais du coup en revenir
ce dont on parle avant est ce que il
faut enlever l'on dit de l'enseignement
des mathématiques
voilà si on change pas l'enseignement
ça me paraît extrêmement probable même
si on n'a pas toutes les volontés mais
révolté du monde conraux l'enseignement
des maths continuer à dégoûter 95% de la
population des mathématiques je pense
que c'est même plus où 95 points
mais alors que si on tente quelque chose
ah oui une priorité que ce soit pire
mais qu'elles me semble une proie été
assez importante que les gens voient
davantage les mathématiques comme
quelque chose de pas forcer sur eux et
voie puisque quelque chose de devoir de
l'exploration je pense très souvent un
langage en termes d'exploration aventure
quand on parle de mathématiques c'est
pas étonnant parce que si on n'a pas en
cette envie d'exploration on ne peut pas
faire des mathématiques
on apprendra de façon mécanique ne peut
pas il n'y a pas de mathématiques son
exploration en pratique en tout cas et
du coup si si c'est plus obligatoire il
ya plus l'opportunité de voir ça comme
de l'exploration et peut-être que les
gens vont explorer de même aller voir
une vidéo youtube ce que font ces gens
qui tombent pas accidents sur des vidéos
youtube de maths et qui vont voir la
vidéo de squeeze une des vidéos
d'excusés sur les maths de dawson et
nous irons voir peut-être creuser un
petit peu plus et je pense que ça ça je
mettrai une probabilité non négligeable
pour que plus que 5% de la population
voit davantage et mathématiques comme
quelque chose à explorer qui leur permet
de de d'explorer un monde extérieur qui
en ressortent de leur coût de leur
quotidien et qui en donnent l'impression
d'avoir fumé un joint et en fait on
était très loin d'avoir fini cette
interview il ya encore presque trois
heures d'interview du coup je vais
laisser ça pour une autre fois en tout
cas merci beaucoup c'est bien pour sept
premiers épisodes et merci à vous
d'avoir écouté cette première partie de
l'interview de sébastien et après une
fois probablement